e
e e
for us being a little late but we just
had a few things we needed to uh uh
straighten out I'm going to call the uh
house Judiciary Committee uh to order
and first I'd ask you to please join me
in the Pledge of
Allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible
with liy and justice for
all thank
you all right um right I'm going to now
open the hearing on House Bill 584
FN uh relative to public health safety
and state sovereignty and I represent I
recognize the uh Prime sponsor
representative green thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee globalism
is an ideology that seeks Global
governance and if you think about it
that's just a fancy way of saying try to
take over the world the point of this
bill is to make it very difficult for
anti-American sabots within government
to violate their Oaths and duties and
try to enforce the will of international
organizations thus undermining our
sovereignty I have an amendment to fix
some small language issues with the
original bill that is 6838 you should
have it in front of you and I'm willing
to answer any questions if you have any
wait a minute hang on what what is the
amendment
number
6838 and if you look at line 12 that's
where the changes in the amendment
are 6838 okay yep let me take a look at
that I'm sorry you said it's on line 12
correct uh let's see okay hang on
all
claims so you know
what yeah you know what you know what
I'm sorry it it I think it I think that
what begins
on line eight of the amendment is meant
to correspond with what begins on line
20 of the uh of the original bill and I
think so I think there it does make
sense correct all right so hang on just
one second let just take
a Mr
chair hang on one
second yes I'm sorry so um obviously I'm
a sub and I've used usually been given a
notebook of all of the bills I don't I
don't have that and I don't have the
bills is y we have I mean there yeah
could I just add Mr
Grant I'd like the binder that I had
last time if I could
represent there if you could just oh
yeah there it is yeah if you could just
pass that down thank you Mr
chair
and you
ex bills in
that wouldn't know but that that would
include these two bills doesn't include
these two bills
sorry I guess I can ask a question of
the if you want to recognize me the
sponsor already ended his testimony I
could ask him a question about the
amendment can
I I'm sorry have I recognized no I was
just asking you to pass the binder down
right so
um representative gr I wondered could
you just tell us what the language
change is specifically so on line 24 of
the original bill it says who create and
enforce policies which rely on the
claims of the World Health Organization
the amendment changes that who enforces
policies mandates orders requirements
edicts or directives of the World Health
Organization and uh the intent of the
bill was never to create any sort of
thought crime and that's why I thought
it was important to make this small
change
okay all right um
okay all right and Roman and am I
correct that Roman numeral 2 of your
amendment that begins on line 14 of the
amendment that that doesn't change from
what's on line 26 of the original bill
is that correct it it's not supposed to
and it it doesn't appear to no okay no I
just that's what I thought but I just
want to make sure all right um all right
great uh uh thank you people have
questions for this
witness representative foran um just to
summarize so the amendment on the one
hand it takes out the creates so you
don't have thought crimes the other hand
I guess it also you apparently felt
there was a Omission because the
original Bill only covered policies and
this also covers mandates orders
requirements edicts and directives is
that
correct so if you look at the first page
of the bill says no rule regulation fee
tax policy or
mandate line three no rule regulation
fee tax policy or Mandate of any kind of
the World Health Organization United
Nations and World economic Forum shall
be enforced so yeah um it if it would be
better with the same exact language that
would be amenable to me in case
somebody's trying to create enforce
something that's not necessarily a
policy but is still a mandate uh order
requirement edct or directive I get it
thanks okay all right um any other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much representative thank
you um next I'm going to call on
um oh boy uh C
Kalin
Ferrar I'm sorry I just can't read the
last name I apologize
hi could you press the
button yeah you know can I just ask you
to spell your last name please sure it's
f r i e r thank you you're
welcome this morning I'm speaking I I
would like to share testimony on behalf
of a colleague who is not able to be
here today but for the record I would
just like to share that I have been a
nurse for 36 years primarily in the
state of New Hampshire and I am
currently the executive director of the
New Hampshire Nurses Association the
testimony I would like to share is on
behalf of a board member of the New
Hampshire Nurses
Association my name is Laura doof I am
honored to be a registered nurse for 35
years in New Hampshire acquiring my
education at community and state
institutions including the New Hampshire
Technical Institute University of New
Hampshire and currently Rivier
University I am a member of several
professional affiliations including the
American Association of critical care
nurses the American Nurses Association
and the New Hampshire Nurses Association
and many others I Rely heavily on a
variety of diverse sources of
information to optimally provide care
for my the diverse patient populations
of which there are many residing in our
beautiful state we are incredibly
fortunate to have the cultural and so
social diversity in New Hampshire that
makes us stronger and more capable if
than if we were all the same the
profession of nursing has an honored
place as the most trusted profession for
the 23rd year in a row according to
respective Gall Gallup pole trust is
something that is severely lacking in
our society and I'm here to assure you
that when you seek care for an illness
or other health care concerns your nurse
will be there for you walking alongside
you making sure you are safe and well
cared for you will be able to trust that
nurse here or she must be knowledgeable
and equipped with the highest quality
information from respected
resources I fear HB 584 will place
nurses in a dire position in the future
as they work to care for patients in new
Hamp in New Hampshire HB 584 is a piece
of legislation that will limit
information from sources that inform my
practice and optimize the care I provide
as well as the care provided by my
nursing colleagues as a professional
nurse who reviews the literature daily I
can recognize its strengths and
limitations and with this Clarity I am
able to support patients choices to
achieve their goals for health is
crucial to have access to organizations
whose mission is to improve the lives of
people around the globe
I am imploring you to vote itl on this
bill a responsible citizen does not
avoid information a responsible citizen
learns from information our state has
always been able to think and act
independent of the current political
Winds of the day I hope you will stand
courageous in defense of Freedom of
Information and our de democracy in
closing I would like to thank you for
your service to our state and our people
we must start to rebuild trust and by
courageously creating and supporting
legislation that is written with the
best intentions you can move us in the
right direction we must start somewhere
thank you right thank you questions for
this
witness did she submit her statement yes
could would you mind submitting that if
you could just bring it up that would be
great thank you very much thank you
thank
you all right um all right seeing no
questions thank you ma'am I'm next going
to call on Melissa blasic
please thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I am Melissa blasik I here
representing rebuild
NH um thank you for the opportunity to
speak today in support of HB 584 which I
have come to refer to as the
anti-globalist ACT this bill is a
crucial step in protecting the
sovereignty of New Hampshire and the
ability of our state to make decisions
free from external mandates that could
come from an organization like the World
Health Organization the United Nations
or the world economic Forum the essence
of this bill is simple it prohibits the
state and its political subdivisions
from enforcing any mandate from these
entities when a version of this bill was
introduced last last year there was some
concern about it being overly broad or
restrictive but I want to clarify that
we are not trying to restrict the
ability of the state to reference
research or guidance from these
organizations when making informed
decisions what we are doing is ensuring
that New Hampshire is not forced into
adopting mandates that could come from
organizations that are not accountable
to our citizens it's important to note
that the scope of the bill has been
expanded from last year to include not
just the wh but also the UN the wef
ensuring broader protections for our
States independence the most pressing
example of potential mandates from
International influences in recent years
has been the who's proposed amendments
to the pandemic treaty while the threat
of those amendments may seem distant we
cannot ignore the fact that there could
be potential reversals in federal policy
after the next election the actions of
President Trump in withdrawing from the
who were a step in the right direction
and I fully support that move however we
must ensure that these protections are
permanent that is why HB 584 is so
important it provides long long-term
safeguards against potential overreach
and ensures that New Hampshire's future
will not be dictated by the political
whims of national or Global
organizations the beauty of Federalism
is that states have the power to make
decisions for themselves we should not
have to rely on nor be subject to the
shifting political currence of national
or International bodies now before there
is an immediate threat we have the
opportunity to act and protect our
rights this bill is not just a
reactionary measure it is proactive and
it ensures that we as a state will not
be forced to follow mandates we do not
agree with I urge you to support HB 584
and make New Hampshire a leader in
protecting State sovereignty and
individual Freedom thank you thank you
questions for this witness yes
representative Burch excuse me without
going into the contents of any mandate
could you for example just tell us uh
for the past five years how many
mandates from the United Nations
uh that uh the state of New Hampshire
has imposed on its citizens just numbers
for the last five years thank you none
again this is a a preemptive bill it's
it's not uh reactive thank you other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much thank you next I'm
going to call on Robert uh laes I hope
I've got that right
good morning um I took a look online and
saw what was coming up for legislation
today and made a kind of last minute
decision to stop by uh after I read what
was going on here I'm sorry you know can
you could I just get a little closer to
the mic sorry about that thank you um
after seeing what was uh happening
legislatively today I thought it'd come
down uh after reading this bill I just
have a couple of questions uh I know you
guys can't answer it so I guess they
going to be rhetorical uh first actually
I'd like to thank the first person that
spoke that was a really well written uh
opposition to this bill uh which my
first question is what's the actual
point of this bill uh to me it actually
it sounds like a bunch of freest State
uh I got to have my sovereignty uh
nonsense that's going to that's actually
going to do nothing as we just
discovered from uh the representative's
last question number two um how about
doing some bills that actually address
problems that we as our citizens have uh
not things that have never happened uh
we have housing problems property
taxes um equal education for poor kids
in in their in school systems that that
aren't getting the
funding to uh to educate them as they as
they should be um third uh oh thank God
we had the that Amendment change because
uh
I'm sure everybody thought they would
we're here to create thought crime
laws
really um and last um performa of
legislation like this just hides the
failure in addressing actual problems of
your constituents I don't know why you
tolerate this stuff I don't know why you
write this stuff it makes no sense you
know I'm sorry dirting your's direct
your comments to the committee okay uh
this bill appears to been written by a
conspiracy theorist who wishes to be a
lawyer um do better right that's
questions for this
wi Happ answer any questions seeing none
thank you very much sir thank you next
I'm going to call on former
representative Betty
gay thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my testimony um that I have very
short testimony for a person who likes
to talk it's um learning to speak in
three minutes is really good um previous
versions of this bill were Loosely
written and I know one of the Reps that
I used to sit next to I heard him
criticize it and say we should get all
the information that we can because that
bill was written so that some people
misinterpreted it to mean that you
couldn't access information from
International organizations
this bill does not does not prohibit any
kind of free exchange of information
what it tries to do is prevent adopting
things from outside that we came across
as
mandates excuse
me uh I'm not sure in the in with our
experience with covid if the all the
dictates that were passed around the
world that unfortunately were copied
here
I'm not sure if it was on a written
mandate or just um uh convincing people
through the media but the result was as
if we were being mandated we had school
closures business closures mandated
masks mandated vaccines if you wanted to
keep your job in many many places so
this is a preemptive statement that we
should make up our own minds about what
our policy should be and not ever let a
an outside International
Organization mandate what we should do
and certainly it sounded like uh some of
the organizations did try to do that so
this is a protection for future for
future needs the next time we have to
deal with something that the world is
concerned about and thinks they have the
solution we need to be able to think of
what really is our best our best and
safest course all right thank you
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next I'm going to call on
Nancy vaugh please
good morning um for the record um I'm
Nancy vaugh um government relations
director for the American Heart
Association in New Hampshire um it's my
pleasure to be before your committee
this morning I don't believe I've ever
been in um in your committee um but I am
um providing testimony to share um my
organization's concerns with the
potential impact of this bill um
primarily as it may impact local
communities um passing um policies um
and uh you know discouraging sound
Public Health policy at the local level
um the American Heart Association
support science-based policy Solutions
at all levels of government recognizes
the importance of local policymaking to
promote and protect public health and
Advance Health Equity and believes in
protecting local governmental power to
advance the health and well-being of its
community members the association
advocates for public policies to create
environments where people can easily
make healthy choices Physically Active
Lifestyles nutritious foods and
beverages living tobacco free we want
everyone to benefit from smart and
effective policies that provote promote
health safety and Civic engagement where
community members can participate in
developing Solutions voicing opinions
and having opportunities for expressing
public support or opposition to policy
change um uh so our concern is really
whether this would have a chilling
effect on any action at the local level
um to address issues that impact that
Community even when would be supported
by a majority of residents and local
leaders um so I um I'll end my testimony
um thank you very much and um hopefully
if you do have any questions I might be
able to answer great thank you very much
are there questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
ma'am thank you uh next I'm going to
call on Aubrey fredman please
uh Mr chairman committee members Aubrey
Friedman I live in Bridgewater I speak
in support of this bill so as was
mentioned we don't have control over the
uh Federal you know what goes on with
the elections administrations come and
go members of congress come and go and
we should be concerned with the future
because maybe things might be okay for a
while but politics change these three
organizations are all rad
and we should not they should not have
jurisdiction here in New Hampshire
especially when it comes to like
mandates okay the world hor excuse me
World Health Organization so they didn't
do a great job during the pandemic and
they've been working on this uh pandemic
response uh uh treaty or excuse me uh uh
agreement to try to get all the
countries to sign on they've been trying
for the last couple of years they have
not been very successful a lot of uh
countries did not want to sign on to it
um they've tried to change it a little
bit in the last year to make it more
easy to swallow for countries to sign on
and uh but they're they've not really
changed at all I went to some of the the
earlier one uh zero draft and I've got
it as part of my backup I'll pass out
afterwards and you look at article 17 it
talks about pandemic literacy
implementation of public awareness
programs this is propaganda this is and
that's that is their thing if you do not
sign on to what how they think the
response should be to any uh pandemic or
big uh outbreak that happens you're in
trouble I mean it's one just like it was
during the pandemic the conspiracy
theories and all that if you didn't
agree with them article 18 talks about
uh National and Community levels this
one Health Plan again they have one idea
for the whole globe and if you don't
sign on to it you're you know this is
you'd be actually in violation if you
signed on and unfortunately do not they
do not consider the health of everyone
because maybe you read about the $250
that wh paid out to the Congo Vic
victims of sexual abuse so evidently
they consider the of everyone except the
people that their employees interact
with uh sexual abuse and that was in the
Congo during the Abola outbreak okay the
UN they have not been all that
successful in the purpose of preventing
Wars obviously but they've been pushing
the Small Arms treaties for years uh the
last one was in 2021 sir you seem to be
getting a little bit off the subject
here of what this bill is about oh okay
um well I just wanted to mention each of
the three uh I talked about the who I'll
just make a brief then okay the don't
like the UN I I think we got it okay
okay and the Small Arms treaties okay
and then the world economic Forum uh
everybody knows about the great reset
they scrubed that from the their website
and but you cannot ignore uh you know
it's still out on the internet CL schab
his statement uh from 2020 the pandemic
represents a rare but narrow window of
opportunity to reflect reimagine and
reset our world so people were dying and
this guy is talking about opportunities
so this organization has not changed um
they're collectivists and they are
Elites so I think New Hampshire needs to
protect ourselves and our sovereignty
those those organizations are not having
be able to reach into
how we deal with uh health or anything
and that's why I support the bill all
right thank you questions for this way
representative Oregon um yeah so the
world economic forum is if is know it's
a private foundation and um I guess you
have doubts about it is there a question
yes would you support are there any
other uh foundations that we should add
to the list like maybe per perhaps Elon
Musk musk Foundation or anything I think
that's I I think that's out of we can
stick with no no I think that question
was out of order we don't need a
response is there any other any any
other questions all right thank seeing
none thank you very much sir thank you
all right is there anyone else who
wishes to I don't have any other pin
cards anyone else who wishes to be heard
on HB 584
FN seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 584 FN and we're a little
early so we can't open the hearing on
580 um so um you know what just uh just
to give everybody a kind of a a a
preview of what I'm what I'm thinking um
here here's what here's what I would uh
oh okay I'm sorry so here's what I'm
thinking I would like to do assuming
that you know things kind of work out um
we'll have the hearing at starting at
10:15 on the next bill then at 11
o'clock we'll start our executive
session what I would like to try to do
um is is to get through what it seems
like based upon my discussions with my
caucus and now also my discussion with
the ranking member things that there may
not be a lot of dispute on try to get
through that as quickly as we can um if
that takes us to say and we'll go until
say 12 o'clock maybe we'll be able to
get through a lot of other stuff then I
would propose that we take a brief
recess at noon so that uh uh people can
have their lunch and that so um if
anybody wants to caucus on the two bills
that we're hearing this morning before
we exec them they'll have an opportunity
to do that over lunch then we'll resume
about 12:30 and and finish up and I'm
what
I'm really hoping we can do because I
suspect a number of people on both sides
of the aisle here would like to get to
the budget hearing at 2 o'clock I
certainly would so I'm hoping that
that'll be a way that we can get all get
through all of this and still be done by
2 o'clock so those of us who want to go
to the budget hearing can do that okay
that's kind of where I'm thinking so
let's take we'll take about 3 minutes
until we can start on 580 thank
you
e
e e
and I'm going to open the
hearing um on House Bill uh 580 FN
relative to retaliatory defamation in
domestic violence and sexual violence
cases um and is um
representative burough I'm going to call
on representative burough the prime
sponsor thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee um for the record um uh
representative Anita burrow from
Bartlett um actually Glenn which is part
of Bartlett and I am here today to
testify on HB 580 um this is a bill that
seeks to prevent retaliatory defamation
for individuals who are reporting
misconduct sexual assault sexual abuse
sexual harassment or domestic violence
and I think the two key parts of this
bill are that it ensures that
individuals who speak out about their
sexual assault and sexual H harassment
are not silenced by the possibility of a
defamation lawsuit as long as their
statements are made in good faith and
without malice I think that's key and
the second thing that this does which I
think is really important um um which
the ACLU pointed out to me to help help
with this said that this also s
safeguards the right for someone to
defend their name and it allows those
accused of sexual assault or sexual
harassment to publicly Proclaim their
innocence without fear of meritless
defamation claims provided that their
statements are made in good faith and
without
malice so how did this bill come to us
um quick story um I um our group of
sponsors was contacted by uh a survivor
of sexual assault she is somebody who um
was asked to go for a drink with a long
long-term colleague of hers both of them
were attorneys the next thing she knew
she woke up in a hospital with a coma in
a coma she had been sexually assaulted
um and she she didn't come out of the
coma for several days and what she said
was her immediate reaction was that she
wanted to she wanted to go to court
against this individual who she had
known for 10 years and a colleague of
hers who was also attorney said you
don't want to do this it's going to blow
up this person is high-profile you
should just keep your mouth shut which
is what she did and then she found out
that another person had had the exact
same experience and she was
mortified um and and angry at herself
that she had not gone forward uh with
pressing the charges so she made it her
to try to pass laws um that would help
protect people from from um being scared
away from Anti-Defamation
lawsuits um now I'm sure people in this
committee know what retaliatory
defamation is but for the record it
refers to when somebody files a
defamation lawsuit against another
person specifically as a means of
punishment for that person using the
defamation claim as a tool to silence or
intimidate them it's considered a form
of retaliation
when false statements are used to harm
the other person's reputation in
response to their action and as you know
these are these are anti-sap laws and
that's a legal mechanism that allows um
that allows a defendant to intimidate or
silence criticism through is often what
is often expensive litigation and again
I'm sure that you folks follow the news
there's been some very high profile
cases involving uh defamation lawsuits
there was Johnny Depp versus Amber herd
um and very recently there are two very
prominent real estate brokers uh from
Miami and New York the Alexander Twins
and and a brother of theirs um who the
the lawsuits against them piling up and
they uh attempted defamatory lawsuits uh
particularly against the first person
who made notion of their activities they
made went to Great Lanes to track them
down and to um um to uh try to
intimidate them through legal action
and now the law makes actually makes it
easier for a private figure than a
public figure to sue someone for
defamation that's because when public
figures are in the news they can often
tell their account of the story and
whereas somebody in in a somebody in a a
um who's not a public fever doesn't have
that options and as I mentioned there
are many compelling stories of victims
who did not report an assault who who
declined to move forward with action for
fear of retaliatory action now the um
salent may be somebody who's who's uh
high-profile in the community it could
be somebody's boss um so the power the
power play there is um there's a
differential in power there and they
people know how much it's going to cost
to have a lawsuit and uh could be three
figures four figures five people five
figures and a lot of these women don't
have I shouldn't say women it's men and
women um know that they're not going to
be able to afford that so um as I said
um this this uh Bill provides two
essential protections it protects
Survivors by ensuring that those who
speak out are not silenced by frivolous
defamation law students again as I said
previous if their statements are made in
good faith and without malice it also
safeguards the right to defense one name
um as long as um
as long as it is done without malice so
um see if there's anything
else so that that basically is it it in
a nutshell um I gave I passed out um I
don't know if I think most of you got it
I passed out statistics from the
national women's um organization about
the prevalence of these um
Anti-Defamation lawsuits they're in
growing a number it's hard to have
statistics here in in New Hampshire but
a lot of them n of them initially came
from uh college campuses but the
national statistics show that that that
that is widening to other types of cases
and so I I think it's important that
victims H are able to come forward
without concern about um they're they're
dealing with a sexual assault they don't
need to deal with a frivolous um
Anti-Defamation case on top of that so I
will end my testimony here all right
questions for this witness
representative bur thank you Mr chair uh
thank you representative Bur
uh for those who didn't uh get a chance
to necessarily see the email uh that you
sent around with the statistics could
you give the committee a flavor of
both how big a problem this is and how
many states have sought to address this
problem through similar legislation sure
I'll just pick out some key key points
here um as I said before um7 7 75% of
defa defamation lawsuits were F filed by
male college students and faculty who
had been been reported for sexual
harassment or assault and since then
these suits have been coming in Faster
it's broadened um defamation in S I know
these are some of these are old figures
but um as of 2017 they saw that the
defamation uh lawsuits had re risen from
5% of of um case loads over the the last
few years of that
[Music]
um a 2020 report found that being sued
for defamation is the third most common
form of retaliation reported by sexual
survivors in the workplace and again you
often have that unequal balance of power
[Music]
um 2018 the United the uh un special uh
report called the act of threatening
survivors with legal pro pro proceedings
a form of uh gender bias I don't want to
go through and read all this
uh you know I think some of this uh some
of this kind of um expanded with the me
too movement um and uh New
Hampshire the one interesting thing that
I found is that New Hampshire is a among
a minority of states that doesn't have
any kind of anti-sap law so I think
that's that's an interesting statistic
um so anyway you can go forth and read
about some of the other states but I I
think the I've said it a couple of times
I think the two keys here are that we're
not only protecting the rights of
victims we're protecting the rights of
those who are falsely accused to to file
a lawsuit we're not trying to prevent
that okay all right other questions for
this witness see that so I guess I have
a question and um the the problem that I
have with all of what you're saying is
you're can you can you sort of tell us
where you say that you know
75% of the lawsuits are are uh file were
defamation lawsuits were filed U by uh
people accused of sexual assault against
their accusers I guess my question
is unless a tribunal of some kind has
decided that a somebody committed a
sexual assault and therefore B that the
person is a victim how do we know
whether those whether you know when
somebody has made a claim of sexual
assault that it's true and how do we
know that it's not true I mean that's
that's the problem I have this seems to
this seems to shift the
balance against the person making um
against the person that's
accused um where there really doesn't
seem to be any we don't know whether
that claim is true or not so how do we
that's the thing I have the most problem
with not not being an attorney I guess I
would answer that by saying that perhaps
in cases where there's a preponderance
of evidence including um DNA and um
maybe eyewitnesses and that kind of
thing there would be definitive evidence
that that um that something happened we
don't know exactly what um and that uh a
defamation a defamation lawsuit um is
not Merit is not not merited right but
but that's but this bill doesn't say
anything about having that kind of
evidence right this this just says that
you've made the accusation so I I I'm
I'm just Cur and I understand you're not
a lawyer and I don't mean to put you on
but for example are were you aware that
for example if somebody is accused of
sexual assault and is actually
convicted that person would
could not bring a lawsuit for defamation
because it would be summarily dismissed
on collateral stoppable grounds so it's
I mean and and you know one one very
prominent public example of that is uh
the the lawsuit uh for sexual assault
brought brought again brought against
the president who was found liable and
he then tried to bring a lawsuit for
defamation against the victim and that
was thrown out on on either a motion to
dismiss or summary judgment because he
had already been found liable
so I my concern is that this seems to
me to say it it it it's sort of along
the lines of well if I claim to be a v a
victim even though I don't have to
actually prove it anywhere I get this
protection and that is a real concern to
me okay can I let me ask you this cuz
your your background if we tweaked
language in terms of putting in
something about preponderance of
evidence would that would that be make a
difference well the I mean I the problem
with that is the the way that you would
determine whether there was a
preponderance of the evidence is through
a legal proceeding in other words that's
what that's the whole purpose of of
either you know if if you if you claim
that you're a victim of sexual
assault you can bring either a criminal
you can you can go to the police and
asked for a criminal prosecution to be
brought or you can bring your own civil
lawsuit against the person you claim
assaulted you and the the process in
which it would be determined whether
there was a preponderance of the
evidence is that proceeding so it you
know it's it's hard for me to understand
how one would ever establish a
preponderance of evidence unless you
actually went to court so I guess that
goes back to how do we solve this
problem of people being scared to come
forward and tell their stories and
eventually prosecute somebody may maybe
be able to prosecute someone if they're
being scared off by these six figure
lawsuits is there do you see any way
that we could protect their a person's
right to come forward and do the suit
and at the same time making sure that
these victims have a voice and that
they're not silenc by this kind of
intimidation which is very
powerful it's it I agree that it's a
it's a it's an important issue I'm just
not sure that
this you know is is the personally that
this is the answer I can only speak for
myself representative Manos thank you Mr
chair
um um I think what's
envisioned I think what's envisioned by
this is that the victim comes forward
files a civil suit against the
perpetrator and the per perpetrator and
while that civil suit is pending the
perpetrator or the alleged perpetrator
then files a defamation suit or
threatens to file a defamation suit and
so what happens is that the victim is
then very reluctant to initially pursue
the civil suit in which as you point out
a judgment would be made by a jury as to
whether there's uh a preponderance of
the evidence to support
to support the victim's claim and I
think this is this is an
intervention to solve that problem where
the threat of litigation uh excuse me um
discourages the victim from even
initially filing the civil suit yeah
yeah well I mean I hear what you're
saying but it doesn't it it said a
victim or other person reporting an
alleged perpetrator's misconduct
reporting what does that mean that
doesn't necessarily mean starting a suit
maybe it means report you know reporting
to the news media somebody has sexually
assaulted me and and the thing I have
the real the most significant problem
with shall be presumed to have acted in
good
faith wow I mean um that that does seem
to me to be I I don't get me wrong I'm I
think that there's a lot of of of people
who are victims who are acting a good F
I don't doubt that for a minute
but presumed I mean that's isn't that's
that's why we generally put the burden
of proof on somebody that's making an
allegation I'm I'm very troubled by by
that can I respond to that I mean and
this is a question for you if a VI like
this woman who who helped initiate this
bill is lying in a coma she's done
there's been a rape test done and it's
clear that she's been sexually assaulted
is that not enough to show that it's not
a frivolous
claim and they can they can tie the the
DNA even before trial to to the uh
person bringing forth the defamation
case well you know I I guess I I I mean
which I don't know the end but it would
seem to me I might need more information
than I mean for example
um I suppose one possibility might be
that the that you know the and again I
don't know all the facts I mean for
example if the if the person who was
accused said sure we had sex it was
consensual sex and we got very drunk
afterwards or whatever and she she fell
and HT and hit her head I I don't know
what all the facts would be but I I mean
I guess what I'm saying is could there
be circumstances in which that what what
happened to the victim would be very
compelling of course I completely agree
yeah but all I'm saying is this doesn't
seem to require any of that it just
requires that you report
and to say that anybody report that
reports is presumed that I'm troubled by
that representative
Burch if I understand the language
correctly uh this is a rebuttable
presumption this is a presumption that
you start with but is
rebuttable so if you want to go into
court um there is a presumption that
when you make a report that you've been
sex
assaulted there's a presumption that
you're acting in good faith now the
other side the can certainly present
evidence to show you're not acting in
good faith and the tri or fact would
then make a decision the there's no need
as I see it to prove the actual fact of
whether a sexual assault took place the
problem is the inhibition
of in most cases women but not
necessarily uh a person who uh wishes to
report that they have been sexually
assaulted that doesn't mean proof of it
they wish to report it and they are
inhibited from doing so by the threat or
the
actuality of being sued by somebody for
six figures or whatever the number is so
the is issue of proving the actual
sexual assault took place is as I see it
a red herring it's got nothing to do
with the harm that this bill seeks to
prevent which is the speaking out either
through a lawsuit or in a newspaper or
whatever to say it without fear if
you're doing it in good faith which can
be shown otherwise if the facts are
otherwise that um uh I was
raped and without a fear of getting
improperly sued and that's what this
bill is about okay well I just sorry
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my
question it it's it's twofold number one
I wonder why why just these two cases I
mean there are a lot of things that are
can you I can't I'm having trouble
hearing I'm sorry I'm sorry my first
question when I read this was why in
just these two instances are we talking
about this there are a lot of things
that go on that unfortunately people do
that um you could feel that they're you
know ruining right okay and then my
other thing is I get
concerned about you said so many of them
were at college campuses I get concerned
about things because I I'm concerned
about Johnny and I break up and I'm
really upset I'm devastated cuz he's
going out with Susie now and I say
Johnny raped
me I get concerned about that right um
and I probably wouldn't have been as
concerned if you hadn't explained that
so many of the cases are I mean people
do nasty things to other people and if
you have no
proof that that would actually happen if
I was Johnny I'd be filing a case
against me too so anyway I just in
response to the last part of what you
said again if somebody ends up in a coma
and they're all beaten up that's a
different situation than than the
scenario that you described
there well it says yes okay I get that
and the first thing you were talking
about is why isn't this broader um
because New Hampshire doesn't have any
anti- slap slap slap
we felt that it was a it was a that we
should start with this and that we
should look I agree we should be looking
at broader anti-s slap issues going
going forward um again uh somebody that
I was working on with this bill was
concerned about um whistleblowers in
terms of land waste and that kind of
thing so absolutely I think that that
this is an important issue that doesn't
just um belong relative to this right
other questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much thank you next
I'm going to call on Pamela Kylie
please uh good morning chairman Lynn and
members of the committee my name is
Pamela kyg and I'm the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak this morning as you
know the Coalition is the umbrella
Organization for our 12 community- based
crisis centers located across the state
um that we provide free and confidential
Services um to thousands of survivors of
sexual and domestic violence annually um
I'm here to speak in support of HB 580
um as you've heard this morning it's an
important legislation that seeks to
protect victims of domestic violence and
sexual assault against defamation
lawsuits passing 580 uh sends a critical
message to survivors across the state
that the legislature is committed to
prioritizing their safety and protecting
their right to speak out without fear of
retaliation
this bill is a significant step towards
discouraging abusers from filing
retaliatory litigation making it safer
for victims to come forward and share
their experiences survivors of Domestic
and Sexual Violence face many barriers
when it comes to reporting their abuse
we frequently hear from victims across
the state about the various tactics that
abusers use to undermine their
credibility and intimidate them into
silence whether it's contacting their
employers filing baseless motions in
custody or divorce proceedings damaging
their credit or threatening harm to the
victim or their children these tactics
are designed to isolate shame discredit
the victim and often trapping them in
the abusive relationship and making it
harder for them to seek help or escape
on average it takes seven times for a
victim of domestic violence to leave
their
relationship the ability abusers to file
um retaliatory lawsuits against victims
only serves to continue the cycle of
abuse further discredit the Survivor and
prevent them from accessing Justice and
I think that's an important thing when
we talk look at this it's not only um
this bill was carefully designed to not
only strike the balance that someone has
to provide uh particular facts not a
general claim um that they have been
abused um but that it ensures um the
right to free speech for victims just as
uh defendants have the right to free
speech HB 580 not only protects victims
but also serves the broader public
interest by ensuring that survivors can
speak out with fear of further harm and
I think it is a public safety bill um
because when victims are silenced um
perpetrators are per permitted to allow
to harm others um so by silencing
victims we're also allowing perpetrators
to continue to perpetuate harm um
retaliatory defamation lawsuits create a
chilling effect Sil silencing the victim
in a particular case but potentially
discouraging other victims from coming
forward as well this bill is an
important safety measure that can help
hold offenders accountable and protect
the general public as you've seen in the
in your committee um it can be very
scary for victims to share their stories
and speak about the abuse they've
entered especially in a public forum
would you want um a constituent who is a
victim of abuse to come forward speak
their story and then have their abuser
file a lawsuit against them for sharing
their truth I think that's really the
root of this discussion do we want
someone who is at a work environment who
reports that a colleague or their
supervisor sexually assaulted them and
then they now have to face a retaliatory
lawsuit for trying to get their Justice
I think that's really the root of what
this is trying to address um the freedom
to share what has happened to them is a
critical part of their ability to seek
Justice
um and so HB 580 helps ensure that a
victim's right to free speech is not
infringed which is important to
effectively addressing these issues in
our state I would just say that we have
um a a concern with um line 15 um
paragraph B due to the nature and degree
of Domestic and Sexual Violence it is
not uncommon for victims to recant or
withdraw their statements after they
report abuse whether it is out of fear
or of further harm or being pressured by
the abuser or their family for or other
reasons um recanting abuse does not mean
that it did not occur um so sub
paragraph B in some ways undermines the
intent of the legislation and reinforces
the dangerous notion that victims are
not credible witnesses to their own
experiences and should not be believed
so I know there was a lot of debate um
you know about the merits of this bill
and balancing Justice uh between victims
and those that they've accused but I
really think this is a common sense Bill
to ensure that we are allowing people to
come forward and we're protecting our
communities by allowing them to do so um
so thank you so much and I'd be happy to
take any questions questions for this
witness yes representative
Smith um thank you very much for for
coming today and
sharing with us your your knowledge
about this
situation
um we
know that anyone is free to go public to
make their uh statements and the
question here is will there be
retaliation how do we stop the
retaliation
um
how can
we
ensure
that the um the accuser in this case
is legitimate in the accusation and not
using the
accusation for other
purposes I think I'm following your
question I'm sorry if it was too obscure
I apologize no it's okay I just don't
want to go in the wrong direction so are
you can you I'm sorry could you give an
example
I think people who have behaved in an in
an
un acceptable way should be held
accountable I have no problem with that
the problem that I have is have they
indeed behaved in an unacceptable way
and is it possible that the
accuser is doing something that is not
quite honorable and that is exactly what
we would not want right the uh the other
party to do so I think and I would like
to just preface that I'm not a legal
expert so I just came in to speak um
from the experiences we've seen um in
working with survivors across the state
um but I think you know the it's a legal
proceeding that this would take place in
and it's pleading particular facts and
not a general claim so it's not someone
just saying that person abuse me but
they have to provide particular facts
and so I don't want to jump into the
actual what that looks like because I'm
not a legal expert um but I do think
that there's a that this would be set up
in a way to really strike that balance
um and I think again we're talking about
situations where someone could be um
sharing their story in a public forum
and then the retaliation lawsuit comes
forward and they have to provide those
particular facts to demonstrate that um
they are indeed a victim so there is a
balance there
thank you so just to follow I'm going to
but just to follow I thank
representative Smith because I think she
she sort of crystallized one issue for
me so if I'm understanding under this
bill if I claim to be a victim of sexual
assault and I bring a civil action
against the person that I alleg sexually
assaulted
me that civil action will proceed as a
normal civil action which means that my
burden of proof against the person that
I allege committed the assault is a
preponderance of the evidence but if
that person claims that I'm I'm the one
that's that's uh not being truthful and
that I that I made up I made up a story
against that person and that person
wants to bring a counter claim against
me that person's burden of proof would
be clear and convincing evidence how is
that fair that that that the fuser gets
to bring a case based on you know a t
just tipping the scales but if I want to
defend by bringing a counter claim I got
to establish it much more by a much
stronger burden to proof how I don't
understand how that's fair um I would
love to just uh consult with some legal
experts on that to provide a more
thorough response but I think that's a
great question and I think the matter of
fairness is something that we all try to
uphold in matters of Justice
um so I I definitely hear what you're
saying and I wish I had um the right
answer um but I do think
that I think that this is an at least
bringing up a really important
conversation um that there is um a
challenge that survivors face and that
there are um victims in New Hampshire
that are being silenced right now out of
that threat or fear of intimidation so I
would just ask the legislature to please
just consider um that something should
be done on this issue representative bur
thank you Mr chair and I before I ask my
question I would note that this bill
does not deal with counter claims this
bill deals with a filing of a defamation
lawsuit uh and this bill deals with the
kind of Gateway concept of whether that
lawsuit should go forward or not uh my
question has to do with that sentence
you that section you pointed out about
um a
recantation and understanding there's
the recantations happen and they're
either valid
recantations or they're not and they're
recanted and unre caned and all that um
given that this is just as I said a
doorway as to whether a defamation suit
can go
through is is there really a problem in
saying that merely the fact that there's
been a
recantation is enough in
itself regardless of whether later
litigation shows it's a real recantation
or not doesn't it really make sense to
say well if there is a recantation we
should let this lawsuit go through the
doorway and let the facts develop as
they are so with that view is there
really that much harm in that particular
section I think that's a great question
and I think from our position we just
caution um the committee just to
recognize that often and um there's
often pressure to recant in these cases
so I think just given the nature of
Domestic and Sexual Violence we just
wanted to flag that paragraph that it
could counter sort of the intent of the
bill but I think um it's a valid point
and um I we just wanted to raise that
from like a again a victim perspective
right other questions for this witness
yes representative Manos thank you Mr
chair I just wanted to um to I don't see
where there's a higher standard of proof
in the text of the bill and I certainly
don't see where it refers to um clear
and convincing evidence well I I look at
line
you might want to look at line eight um
unless it is shown by clear and
convincing evidence that's yeah that's
in the amendment sorry I'm not speaking
to the amendment I'm speaking to the
underlying bill I haven't seen the
amendment just to clarify my
testimony all right other questions for
this witness representa T yeah just
listening to this um it seems like the
goal and I'm not sure it's in the bill
is to tie the initial uh lawsuit which
may or may not be part of um a criminal
case to the what would be the
retaliatory lawsuit you know not just
the threat of it but maybe the act the
fact of it such
that what we're really saying is if the
if the initial accusation is borne out
then that
person
would not should not have to bear the C
cost of the retaliation and I I I'm
wondering was that a consider is that in
some way read into this or was that a
consideration to basically allow a
contingent a contingency on a on a on a
lawsuit like that such that if the
original you know accusation is borne
out then that person would be
responsible for the for the costs of of
their their
lawsuit um yeah so I think if I'm
following your your line of question so
I the underlying bill um paragraph 4 um
says a victim who prevails in a
retaliatory defamation case at any point
in the proceeding shall be awarded court
costs and reasonable attorney fees so I
I do think that is an like if I'm
understanding what you asking correctly
I do think that is an important piece of
just again what the imbalance that
currently exists in a lot of Domestic
and Sexual Assault cases where a lot of
frivolous lawsuits are brought up or
continued motions and things like that
where victims spend 10 10 T of thousands
of dollars in court proceedings just
because um the abuser keeps filing
motions so I do think that again within
the larger context of what we're seeing
in the state this is just adding another
checkin balance to what is often a
continuation of abuse can I can I ask
one quick follow up on that of course so
just on that on that idea and this was
something I was confused with in reading
this and maybe I'm mistaking which suit
we're talking about in the in the last
paragraph versus above but the up above
on line six it says shall not file the
defamation lawsuit and then at the end
um we talk about um someone who prevails
in a retaliatory defamation case so are
those the same like one of them's
preventing it from happening the other
one basically assumes some sort of uh
prevailing uh result of it am I am I am
I mixing those up I think be and this is
me again not being a legal expert so I'm
going to try my best so I think because
they will bring forward the case you
have to them the victim would then have
to provide particular facts to
demonstrate that they indeed are a
victim so there would be costs
associated with having to go through the
process I
think other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much next I'm going to call on
uh former representative Betty gay
please
thank you for taking my testimony I
realize that everybody is concerned
about people being falsely confu con I
just forgot the word falsely accused and
suffering uh terribly to their uh public
knowledge however in reality we have far
more victims of sexual abuse who then
are Mar marked who are scared to death
to say that they've been raped because
the ordinary response for the culture is
to say what did you
do so we already have in our culture the
reluctance to report sexual
abuse so it takes a lot of gumption and
that's why as uh as our previous
testimony said usually
people uh go back to their abuser seven
times because they're so many ties so
many reasons why not to risk your entire
life and everybody's opinion of you
there are two really important facts one
is settling one court case will solve
both
cases if you accuse someone of sexual a
sexual assault and you're
found it's founded it's a agreed that
that really happened obviously the
second case is not going to
happen so you save a lot of
time forensic can tell whether a person
engaged in consensual sex or was
raped it's no longer ex considered it's
exactly the same it is
not I think I think it's really really
important to acknowledge that being
threatened with a suit of many figures
of many big numbers is enough to deter
lots of people for lots of lots of
things that is a genuine genuine threat
and in our culture it's hard enough for
victims of ab of sexual assault to prove
that they are or to convince other
people that they were not willing
participants so you start out with
something that's
cultural not in the
law but I think I think this bill is
very very important to pass because it
gives if if the person who um I wish my
words were better but if the victim
accuses someone and does follow through
in court and
wins great great the the person's not
going to not going to file against can
they could file against them they still
have that that uh uh that
opportunity but we're we're if we don't
pass this we're ignoring a really
serious threat that victims of sexual
abuse suffer from and I think it's time
that we level the
field thank you questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much next I'm
going to call on uh uh Marissa Chase
please good morning Representatives um
thank you for um taking my testimony for
the record my name is Marissa Chase I
represent the New Hampshire Association
for justice which is um the Civil
plaintiff's bar of um attorneys in the
state um I come here with um
total respect for the sponsors and the
intention behind this piece of
legislation just some practical concerns
um with the definitions I think RSA 507
is maybe perhaps and I guess I should
also preface with I don't think this is
totally unworkable I don't think every
single anti slap piece of legislation is
unworkable I think there are some ways
to do it that might comport better with
New Hampshire law I don't think this
bill quite fits that yet um I think RSA
507 is perhaps a weird statute to put it
I think some of the definitions and I
think Mr chair you brought up a lot of
the concerns that and a lot of the kind
of thinking through rational arguments
that my members did when we discussed
this bill um you know this bill doesn't
necessarily Define what a victim of
sexual assault is while a lot of times
colloquially we know inherently What
legislation is aiming to get at legal
terms can be quite different as you all
know from your work on this committee um
also what is the victim publicly stated
means I don't know if anybody's watched
the office but I'm reminded of when
Michael Scott declares
bankruptcy um and I also wanted to add
that um our courts in New Hampshire have
found punitive damages at the end and
I'm sorry I'm reading from the bill is
introduced not any Amendment um a victim
who pre who prevails at any point in the
proceeding shall be awarded cost
freeable attorneys fees shall be
eligible to receive punitive damages we
don't really have punitive damages in
New Hampshire we have enhanced
compensatory damages punitive damages um
are kind of I should say frowned upon um
the other thing I would
note is escaping me at the
moment um I apologize I just completely
lost my train of thought but if there is
a will on this committee to work on this
legislation and try to come to
compromise um my members would be more
than happy to participate with other
stakeholders all right questions for
this witness yes yes represent bur uh
you suggested that the uh oh thank you
for taking my question and it's good to
see you good to see you representative
uh you suggested that the definitional
part of victim or whatever is isn't
defined uh and I'm not sure if you're
familiar with the amendment no okay so
the amendment says a victim or other
person reporting an alleged perpetrator
sexual misconduct sexual abuse sexual
whatever thank you so I'm looking here
now that you have it at at line six and
seven
and so I also think I'm looking at um
well I guess I have a concern with line
eight but I'll stick to your question
line six and seven uh victim other
person under 17 so I think victim is
defined in 173b probably makes sense but
again I think that creating rebuttable
presumption I mean has a criminal case
happened or not when is this civil
action being commenced in conjunction
with the civil case and I remembered my
train of thought if I may to piggyback
off this discussion uh in New Hampshire
we are such a small state with a
collegial bar and we're a cheap state
right we're Frugal juries are the same
and frivolous lawsuits just
don't often get filed in New Hampshire
we are not some state that welcomes
outof State multi-district litigation we
are a small collegial bar where lawyers
reputations depend on their work and
vice
versa and lawyers take these cases on
contingency fee basis that means that a
lawyer who would take this case would
not get paid unless and in until they
Prevail and get a recovery on behalf of
their client that in itself is a huge
deterrent to bringing any claims that
are not meritorious in this state and I
just wanted
to make that point but I think the
definition of victim of 173b in the
amendment makes sense clear and
convincing evidence I in civil cases
that's just not a standard that we
typically see um civil cases um are
typically by preponderance of the
evidence clear and convincing is when
you're taking someone's Liberties away
it's a much higher evidentiary standard
so I always get wary when we see clear
and convincing in civil context all
right other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you all right is there anyone else here
who wishes to uh be heard on House Bill
FN seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
58 e
you have two minutes I have some copies
of amendments we can pick
up oh um yeah you know
um
722 72 722 okay um hang on one second
722 where where is
722 I do it later oh okay um yeah yeah
yeah you know we're going to we're going
to we're going to just find it EXA now I
think we'll be but then we'll take a
break
um oh I'm s oh I'm s you know I'm sorry
I didn't you know you reminded me and I
didn't do it I'm sorry so
um uh based based upon a just a very
brief discussion I had with the ranking
member let me ask and I I really I guess
I I don't since neither neither of us I
think have had a chance to talk to our
respective caucuses about this so I'm
sort of you know shooting from the hip a
little bit maybe maybe both of us are
but she raised the issue um which I
think is worthy of at least a discussion
with regard to the last bill we the bill
we just heard 580
um I believe that there would be
significant dispute among
and maybe it would be on a partisan
basis maybe not I'm not sure but there
would be significant dispute about what
should happen to that Bill I'm wondering
if everyone could live with retain the
bill um and what I'm thinking there is
this uh you know for example just I'm
and I'm completely Thinking Out Loud
here I this might be satisfactory to
some people or not would for example
would
a potential
way that could bring everybody together
on this bill would be if over the summer
for example we worked on some language
that said something
like um
if a person that is accused
of sexual assault or sexual abuse of
some kind is
adjudicated to have engaged in that
abuse then if it's a criminal case as
part of the criminal case the court is
required to
award compensation to the victim for any
expenses he or she might have incurred
in defending against the lawsuit or the
same if it was a civil case in other
words a requirement that um if you if if
you are actually guilty of some kind of
assault and you have have have attempted
to use a a civil lawsuit against the
accuser um you're going to you're going
to have to pay the
piper
um in the if if in if in fact you're
found to have engaged in abuse um so I I
I raised that issue as a possibility of
something we might think about and that
would that be a reason to retain this
bill Mr chair could I Mr let me hear
from representative Smith first and then
representative B
um I I know we're not on the subject of
this bill it hasn't been called for the
executive session so we're not ready at
all to discuss it um my only comment to
you was preliminary to you getting to it
in in the calendar and that there seem
to be strong
um uh both questions and affirmations on
each side and because we try to work as
collegially as we can in this committee
it might be appropriate on this bill not
to discuss what we could come up with
but to discuss that we ought to think
about what we could come up with and
therefore it would make sense to retain
it have a subcommittee perhaps work on
it see what they come up with see if we
can get either to a yes or a no that is
clear to all of us and that was my own
my reason for my comment not that I see
a
suggestion right now you're much more
knowledgeable than I am you see
suggestions now but um rather than go
into what I think would be a highly
contentious discussion at this point
that I don't think anybody wants it was
just when you got to it in the
agenda to consider
retaining as the answer to get us
through to the end all right
representative bur you had something you
want say I I would strongly argue
against that I mean we've
heard I have some doubts frankly that
those who who philosophically oppose
slap litigation or anti-s slap
litigation are going to come up with a
solution that is slap litigation so I'm
not sure what a retention would do as to
the
suggestion that if a criminal case
proceeds to prove the allegation then
the defamation suit suit wouldn't happen
we already have that and the idea if a
civil suit shows that the sexual assault
happened that we would switch to a loser
pay system which is not what we have in
New Hampshire and I doubt would ever
pass uh as that concept I I just think
that uh that absent asense from those
who clearly oppose to slap litigation
that they're willing to
consider um slap
litigation uh uh prohibition that
there's not much point in having a
retaining it right discuss get the
bill not in ex well I no I thought I did
open the did I not open but not to this
well you just opened it generally and so
unless you you were taking this bill out
order and I would hope you wouldn't
since neither CAU has had a chance to
discuss this after the hearing I would
hope you would just move on now to the
order of bills that well okay I I guess
I thought that we if it sounds like what
you're saying representative Smith and
if that if it is the case I have no
problem with this that you would like a
chance to talk with your caucus about
this and that's fine with me so I will I
will uh put this off until probably
after lunch I guess what I would like
can I where's the representative of
Alexander
see
okay I'm
sorry yeah but the time for that is not
now
somewhere all right hang hang on hang on
let
me oh okay
hey just
about yeah ready to go now oh yeah all
right so
um I so if I hadn't done so before I'm
going to formally open the executive
session now and I am going to take um
uh I'm going to take up out of order
House Bill 633 FN relative to housing
Investment Trust because I see at least
one or two of the uh of the the sponsor
and someone who else else is who's very
interested in this bill here and in
deference to not having them have to
wait around um I think it makes sense to
take that up first
so um with regard to uh HB 633 the chair
recognizes representative
Alexander uh uh to speak I believe he
has a motion thank you Mr chairman I
move um HB 633 ought to pass and I offer
Amendment um 2025
860h right is there a
second I'll second the moot I'll second
the
motion um and representative Alexander
would you like to speak to your motion
yes Mr chair thank you I I saw that
there's significant value in something
like this and I'd like to study it
further um I also think there were a lot
of questions raised during the public
hearing um that could be answered
through a true legislative study
committee this amendment would replace
the bill with a legislative study
committee it would consist of um three
representatives and one Senator um the
reason why I want to do a legislative
sub uh study committee instead of a
retain is because I want to get buyin
from the Senate um or the other body um
to see uh to hopefully get to a point
where we can have a a clean consensus
moving into next year so that's what
this amendment does and I'm hoping that
I can offer up a great version of this
bill that the committee will support and
it will fly through the state house next
year so I ask for your support um all
right anybody uh wish to be heard on uh
representative Alexander's Amendment um
yes sure rep um the way the bill is
drafted is kind of strange too I didn't
well I C the fact I didn't 100% follow
the concept but maybe that's just me but
also like it just defined those trusts
and then it there was didn't make any
other changes anywhere in the law books
I wasn't wasn't sure like uh what effect
just are defining these things here if
you don't have any other law that says
how they how they operate so that's um
definitely an issue that a study
commission would probably want to
committee would want to look like look
like in advantage of having a study
committee I guess over retaining it is
then you can bring in people from uh
from other you could there's three reps
and one Senator so you can bring it well
you can bring in a senator obviously but
also you could bring in reps from
outside this committee with with uh such
as from the housing committee so I guess
that's the advantage of having the study
committee instead of just retaining it
all right anyone else wish to be heard
representative Smith my only comment is
I um applaud representative Alexander's
optimism that he can get a senator to
show up thank you other uh
representative p no yes thank you Mr
chairman um aside from the fact that I
wish representative this had gone to
representative Alexander's committee on
housing so we didn't have to vote on a
study committee here um I randomly ran
into a diff another State Rep last week
while I was subbing on another committee
and he suggested a similar idea so I
think there is an appetite that I wasn't
expecting and I forwarded this
information onto him and I know he for
one would like more opportunity to look
into this topic anyone else wish to be
heard so I guess I would say I I should
note um I had the
opportunity U to meet with
representative Daniels and Mr Delano Who
U it was it was a pleasure to meet with
them on Saturday of this week to talk
about this bill and I from my
discussions with them um I I I tend to
think that this you know this has great
perspective great potential at least it
seems to me to have great potential as
something that you know the legislature
would would want to uh move forward with
um but as representative Alexander
points out there are a number of things
that I think we need to have more
information on I mean just as an example
two things that come to mind to me is um
despite um uh Mr
Delano's
efforts uh to explain it to me I'm not
clear that I completely understand what
the interest of some somebody who became
who bought one of a house or a unit uh
under the under one of these trusts
apparently would be referred to as a
householder um and I'm not quite sure
how that how the how a householder's
interest would compare with the owner of
a fee simple or the owner of an interest
in a condominium that kind of thing and
the other thing is I apparently there
are there is some this would have some
tax implications on
uh the uh the u local municipalities
which I think would you know is a is a
matter that we would want to get more
information on so I think that the idea
of Representative Alexander's uh study
committee despite the fact that he's
going to have to hear from the speaker
about his displeasure over St study
committees if ever there was one that
was worth it this seems to me it it it
is um and so I support U this this
amendment um and I'm going to I'm going
to uh vote for it and then vote for the
the bill as amended representative
bur thank you Mr chair uh I want to
explain why I will vote against this
amendment um I'm
concerned that uh about the tax aspects
of this I'm concerned about the
potentiality of Sheltering money um that
would normally go into the state uh
coffers and
I have my own doubts whether the
fundamental
structure of what this bill attempts to
do uh would be changed by a study
committee rather than uh tinkering with
it so I I don't support a study
committee all right anyone else wish to
be
heard all um so I can I just I'm I this
is we're dealing with the amendment only
now now um uh any can I just ask for uh
is anyone anyone going to require a a
roll call vote on the amendment if
anyone is I will do it if anyone asks
for one I will do it all right so can I
ask for a show of hands on
representative Alexander's Amendment
2025 860h all those in favor please
raise your
hand right any opposed all right so it's
uh
17 16 to 1 sorry all
right hang
on
33 all right and then on the uh so the
the amendment passes we're now on to uh
the main Bill uh which would be
otpa uh anyone anyone else wish to be
heard on representative Alexander's
motion the main motion of
otpa seeing none I then ask the clerk to
please call the
role Vice chairman Manion yes
representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew
representative kab yes representative
Perez yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarlin
yes representative
Smith representative Horgan yes
representative Burch
no representative Harvey yes
representative Manos
yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo
yes representative buron yes and
chairman Lynn
yes 16 Ys one
nay all right um and this
uh
okay all right H yeah Hy hang on um give
me one second 633 all right
um I'm sorry so 16 to one on the otpa
right
okay are we
going
16 hang on uh TP right y uh Paul do you
have any objection if this go all
representative B I apologize you have
any objection to this going on consent
uh Mr President I have no objection
thank you all right all right um
representative Alexander can I ask you
to write the report absolutely thank you
U he's no I represent Alexander is
actually always very prompt on getting
minority uh no there'll be no minority
all right
um
e e
sorry I'm turning uh going to turn to
exact uh House Bill 620 FN relative to
the exercise of the freedom of religion
and the chair recognizes representative
petal for a motion thank you than you Mr
chair I move ought to pass on House Bill
620 all right and I'm going to second
that motion uh representative pel do you
wish to speak to your motion yes I think
this is an important um piece of
legislation for our state it is um
freedom of religion is recognized um
through the courts but this would um
recognize it through statute and would
would require compelling interest test
um which means that a substantial burden
um would have to be proven so it's not
just like you're
randomly um practicing your religion it
would have to be a compelling interest
that does the government have an um very
good reason to interfere with your um
Freedom right to practice religion and
the least restrictive means is there an
alternative method to serve the public
interest um I think this has been
enacted in multiple States and with the
increasing number of attacks on
religious freedom it's it's necessary to
um Implement in New
Hampshire anyone else wish to be heard
on um House Bill 620 FN uh
representative Burch um I'm an
opposition to this uh proposed
legislation microphone oh mic sorry
sorry I'm in opposition to this proposed
legislation it's not necessary we have a
New Hampshire Supreme Court decision on
this very matter it has set out the law
it's not particularly different than
this legislation since the New Hampshire
Supreme Court is ultimately the
controlling voice on uh the
constitutionality of such bills that um
there's no need to do it that State
versus Mack now it's been
suggested that if the state supreme
court changed its
mind then we would have a state statute
but that's kind of a loser because if we
had a state statute that didn't pass the
New Hampshire Supreme Court definition
of or decisions about
constitutionality the fact that we have
a statute would be uh overturned by the
Supreme Court so basically I don't
support passing legislation where
there's no demonstrated need for it uh
it just creates potential conflicts
between bodies that are supposed to work
cooperatively we did have testimony also
that there's no definition here of
religion and religious beliefs and uh
the the spectrum of what's religious
beliefs and not can go uh pretty far a
field and whether we as a leg
legislature can be involved in defining
someone else's religious belief or
religion
is I'm not just thinking about the
Church of Satan uh but maybe a step too
far in what we need to do given we
already have a ruling from the New
Hampshire Supreme Court thank you right
anyone else wish to be heard
representative
couta I Echo much of what rep Burch said
and I also just wanted to add that there
was the concern about zoning related to
religious use
purposes in relation to this bill and
for that reason I just can't support
this bill although I do absolutely
support the freedom of religion thank
you all right anyone uh yes
representative H um yes I I don't agree
with the premise that uh religious
freedom is under attack or at least any
more so than any other freedoms are
under attack which U so I'm not sure why
an activity deserves more protection or
less protection just because it calls
itself a religion as opposed to whether
it calls itself uh something else so I
think um so I think this bill is uh I
think as a I think this bill uh is if if
it does anything useful at all is
probably use at all is probably
counterproductive and in any case uh I
wouldn't say there was no definition of
religion in the bill but it was sort of
a circular definition but it does refer
to back to several U several provisions
of of these federal and state
constitutions I'm not sure this this
doesn't add anything to what's already
in the Constitution it just creates more
TR trouble than it solves and of course
it's it's unfair to institutions and
organizations activities that don't
describe themselves as religious as
opposed to those which do describe
themselves as religious so I'm I'm not
voting for this bill thanks all right
other anyone else wish to be heard so I
guess I would just what I would say is I
tend to support this I think that it is
uh important and I think it's um it's
it's worthwhile to just look at a little
bit of history of this the the whole
idea of religious freedom restoration
acts um started after a 1996 1990 I
believe decision by the US Supreme Court
that basically said that a any law as if
a law was of General applicability the
fact that it might have might have a um
uh a particular
detrimental impact on religion was not
enough to to
uh uh to say that the law interfered
with uh freedom of religion that my
recollection is that decision by the
Supreme Court was was uh greeted with
bipartisan uh condemnation and it was a
bipart the Congress of the United States
passed the religious freedom restoration
act on a by bipartisan vote
the need for a state equivalent to that
arose because there was a another later
Supreme Court case Flores versus
somebody uh in involving I think a in uh
in Texas uh in which the Supreme Court
said that while Congress
could Grant greater protections to
Religious Freedom in federal matters it
didn't have the authority to do that at
the state level that would be a
violation of the um the 14th Amendment
or in order the supremacy clause and so
that's why we have this um it seems to
me to be pretty important I don't see um
the you know the concern on the with the
zoning issues if the if a state if a
state or a municipality has some uh uh
compelling interest for why um a church
or or some some religious activity
shouldn't shouldn't be happening in a
particular place or whatever they they
they that will prevail but it does say
that it it's got to be something that's
that's pretty important in order for the
state to interfere with religious
activity so I think I think the bill uh
makes sense and I intend to support it
other anyone else uh wish to be heard
all right I I seeing none I guess I'd
ask the clerk then to call the role
please on the um the motion is OTP
on uh House Bill
620 Vice chairman Manion yes
representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes Representative
kutab no representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes representative C
yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative bur
no representative Harvey no
representative Manos no representative
tur no representative Rambo no
representative Bergeron
no and chairman Lynn
yes nine y nine Nays all right so um the
uh the OTP
um fails is there another motion
yes representative bur I would move
itl right is there a second
oops hang hang on
um
um turn
all right any uh any further discussion
yes representative Perez this can't go
to the floor like this with no
recommendation well we have no but we
have to have a vote on the o on on the
itl I think it then will go to the floor
with no recommendation but we have to
have a vote all right so the the uh an
itl motion has been made by
representative Burch seconded by
representative tur does anyone else wish
to be heard on uh on the itl
motion right seeing none I'd ask the
clerk then to please uh call the
role Vice chairman
Manion no representative
Alexander
no representative trip no representative
Andrews no representative cab yes
representative
Perez clerk votes no representative
McFarland
no representative C no representative
Smith yes representative Horgan yes
representative Burch yes representative
Harvey yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo yes representative berson yes
chairman Lynn no uh on the itl um
no sorry about
that a senior moment
nine nine y nine y nine Nays all right
all right um so it appears that we will
go with uh it'll go to the floor with no
recommendation um representative pno
will you write the uh report for oot uh
for the OTP and who will write the
report for
itl I'll do it all right um
representative
Burch
um all right all right um next um
see anybody else raising their
hands all right next I I'm sorry next
I'm G to turn to
uh HB um
641 um relative to establishing a
private right of action for civil rights
violations and uh the chair uh recogn
izes um representative Alexander for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move in
expedient to
legislate I right representative Perez
you have a second I second all right so
it's moved by representative Alexander
seconded by representative Perez
representative Alexander do you wish to
speak to your motion yes very briefly I
think um the testimony from the Attorney
General's office was very enlightening
on this um they indicated there are only
about 215 complaints last year um 50 to
55 of them Rose to certain standard that
it need to get investigated and I made a
point to ask um if the AG feels like
they have sufficient staff to
investigate these claims and um address
them and they indicated that they do um
so I just don't think this bill is
needed at this time um so I would
encourage my colleagues to vote
itl right anyone else wish to be heard
representative Rambo I just wanted to
mention I I don't know that anybody's
gotten a chance
to see this but it appears that there oh
is that what's just gotten handed out
the amendment that just came out we just
got notice of an potential Amendment uh
from the AG's office so I I just didn't
know if there was further discussion on
that particularly this was just this is
not in addition to what you're just
talking about sorry I just I just saw an
email come in recently and I wasn't sure
if we had missed something on an
amendment just wanted to clarify yes uh
representative gthr had um emailed the
Judiciary Committee just 10 minutes ago
um saying that there is a potential
amend amendment I told her if my motion
of itl fails uh we can entertain the
emotion uh the motion but actual or
threat I mean I I still with the
amendment would move it I just wanted to
get it out there thanks could we just
clarify because I have an amendment in
hand the number is
0406 is that the number we're talking
about there no there's another one that
just came in our inbox it's not a formal
Amendment it's I believe it's just text
of an amendment it's not a drafted one
um representative gar had said it to us
via email so and so I you know I should
say
um can I I I I didn't see that because I
had you know I haven't checked my email
since left but but am am I correct
representative Alexander that the
substance of that would be to allow the
Attorney General to
intervene uh in in
cases I think that's the amendment
0406 that we all have and should be
moved that has the right to intervene I
don't know what the one I haven't seen
yet says there's new language that would
add uh a sentence saying if the court or
jury finds that the actual or threatened
use of force violence property damage or
trespass was a willful or knowing
violation of this
chapter okay okay that's the additional
sentence I think representative garth's
not nodding at me Mr chair so yeah uh
representative bur uh I know I know it's
proper not often done at at executive
sessions uh to ask somebody who's not on
the committee perhaps to speak and I see
the representative here is here and
maybe the representative can explain the
bill for those the Amendments if it's if
we're discussing the amendment well I
she's here um
I I guess what I would say is um
I mean
we
it we don't have a drafted Amendment
this bill was was noted for executive
session uh in a in proper form um
representative G I guess I yes I'll if
you want to speak very briefly to what
the amendment does I think that really
is the the only thing um and I'm that's
not to say that we're necessarily going
to take up the amendment but I think
it's appropriate to hear what you have
to say
about uh thank you Mr chair and
Judiciary Committee my name is Linda
Harriet gath right I'm out of uh NASA um
w nine so I just received unfortunately
I just realized that it was sent to me
at 9 something this morning but I was
back here on my computer for the first
time today and saw it that um it was
sent to me by the ag office by Sean um
and so I wanted the opportunity to get
the amendment mment and that's what made
me send you guys what the statement that
he made this was something that was in
the hearing um section two I think of
the bill that he wanted to make a change
it's not the one that he made he made
the change on the original that you have
there that allow them to have access but
this is totally different and I think
this is something that representative
bir had brought up and had the
conversation so all right so is this
something that deals with the language
of about a settlement yes okay this is
in section
two okay I'm just getting to see it
myself actually
okay oh
sure I literally just saw this one I
sent it to you all okay so I haven't
sent it but I can send it over to them
and if you would hold off toat today I
mean
it's well any anybody else have any any
questions for the yes representative
yeah Mr chairman I just want to make
sure I'm understanding correctly I I see
the email but I don't see any attachment
from OS is it just the language in line
that's not been written up by
s yes this is the language that was sent
to me to send to OS okay so that there
isn't actually an amendment from NOS
though right am I right so all right
representative forgan like um Sean Lock
who's an Assistant Attorney General he
he sent us the proposed language I guess
Senate to her and then another
individual and the text of the email
rather then as a file attachment but
right OS probably could all right but
there's enough there for OLS probably to
all right thank you very much
representative go appreciate it
so it sounds like I'm sorry
representative
Smith oh no I I guess what I was going
to say is it sounds like the language
that if I'm understanding correctly from
um what represented Manion showed me uh
it it doesn't sound like this language
really would have any effect at least in
my view and I think in Al representative
Alexander's view I suspect in the view
of at least my caucus on whether on how
we would vote on this bill so um in
light of that um I'm I'm not inclined to
uh to go further with the amendment
representative
Smith um Mr chair um I might have Mish
heard my longtime dear
colleague from um gtown about when he
talked about the numbers of people I
wondered if he could tell me what number
of people denied their civil rights
would be
acceptable before the state should step
in I think he said something like 24
that's obviously below his standard
could he tell me what the standard would
be there is currently nobody's thank you
for the question to my dear friend from
Durham um there is currently nobody
being denied civil rights violation
that's not being adequately already
invested by the AG's office this bill is
not
needed right all right anyone else wish
to be heard on this so I guess I should
say um because I had a I had a a
discussion with representative goth last
evening um I listened to the entire
hearing on this bill and what I was
taking away with um were a couple of
things first of all I think it's really
important to understand that it is not
true that at the present time there is
no basis for an individual to bring a
claim um who has had their civil rights
violated um in in the manners that are
described in RSA
354b I I as I looked at the
statute and you know based on the common
law it would be it would be a rare case
in which something that would violate
RSA
354b um would not also very likely
amount to a common law tort
of assault or battery or false
imprisonment or or defamation or
invasion of privacy or some other common
law tour could there theoretically be
some I suppose it's possible would the
remedies I mean one of the things that I
I remember hearing from the from the
testimony at the hearing was a concern
that well a court
um uh it's only under the statute that a
court could could Grant injunctive
relief I that's not my understanding of
the law if there's if somebody brings a
common law lawsuit and alleges that
somebody assaulted me and there's a
threat that they're going to continue to
assault me in the future or harass me or
do whatever you can get an injunction in
that circumstance also uh under the
common law I think courts are fully uh
uh capable of granting that kind of
relief um so I think that that really
builds upon what representative
Alexander had said
that this legislation is just not
necessary um and I um and and again the
other thing that I think was very
important that rep that uh Mr Lock
indicated in his testimony was that this
is not it's not this is not at all a
situation where the AG's office is
overwhelmed with cases that um that are
are brought to their attention and they
can't bring or seek relief for all the
cases that that exist that he said that
their their office is fully able to
handle the cases that are brought to
them so that again reinforces
representative Alexander's position uh
for those reasons I intend to support
the itl motion anyone else wish to be
heard on
this all right seeing none I would ask
the uh clerk uh to call the role the
motion is itl on House Bill
641 Vice chairman Manion yes
representative Alexander
yes representative trip yes
representative
Andrew representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes
representative C
yes representative Smith no
representative Oregon no representative
bir no representative Harvey no
representative Manos
no representative tur no representative
Rambo no Representative berson
no chairman Lynn yes 10 y eight Nays all
right all right um representative
Alexander could I call you to write the
uh
majority I'm
sorry but what is the
um what is the count it's 10
to8
yes
thank we have a we have a
sub she voted I think representative kab
did you vote Yes is that correct yeah
it's 10 to8 I'm very sorry I thought she
voted all right so representative
Alexander will write the majority report
who will write the
minority did somebody else yeah
somebody all right rbo minority okay I
have a question of the chair if the
since there was a we did have that email
chain with the proposed amendment in it
so would that have to be a floor
Amendment if somebody wanted to move
forward with it or could it be a
minority Amendment um I
hasn't drafted it wasn't I suppose yeah
I think it would have to be a floor
minute if the itl motion fails uh then
there would be an opportunity for
another motion yeah because what he had
looked like it could very easily be be
drafted but it hasn't been
drafted would be the majority right the
minority would
beot floor with a floor Amendment
right um
we have to um have a floor Amendment
drafted and she can get the information
obviously right from either the Attorney
General all right um
um no no no no no no you're right you're
right I know
that's
um see what else I
down all right um
so
um I have samp none of these things
are all right all right next I'm going
to take up um House Bill
FN and uh the chair recognizes uh
representative Alexander for a
motion um thank you Mr chairman um I
move ought to pass and I offer Amendment
332h um I had if first of all wait for a
second then I can
speak 0332
H um I had distributed to the committee
uh a few weeks ago I have copies I can
hand those around
too here
all right so let me uh so um hang on let
me back up
um so uh representative uh Alexander uh
moves uh his Amendment and I'm uh for
the record I will second that um
representative Alexander do you wish to
speak to your uh on the amendment yes so
um it should be no surprise to the
committee that this is a great bill and
I think you should vote for it um there
were a couple things raised during the
public hearing um so this amendment
makes two changes first it um
addresses um it does the address of
library card Library membership status
keeps that but it removes on line 16 it
used to be any member of the public
library or Library staff it removes
member of the public public um so it's
just library or Library staff and then
it doubles the Civil penalty from 500 to
1,000 um but it doesn't it changes the
the term restitution payment to civil
penalty uh which was a suggestion during
the public
hearing all right all right anyone else
wish to be heard on uh the amendment to
uh
666 oh yes yes ma'am uh thank you Mr
chairman I was actually here for the
hearing of this this bill and um I'm
also a member of nlta I have no problem
with library cards and Library
membership status being um private and
and not open to the public and I believe
this committee already passed a bill
that did just that I do have
reservations with the um the damages
that are being
assessed I I thought even the original
bill of 500 with a um apology that's
notorized in public and so forth I just
feel that like the damages are Way
Beyond what um the crime so to speak is
um you know these sometimes in small
libraries Library staff people only
work very minimum hours during the day
and um something might have happened
that they are not not even sure about so
I just I just don't like um what is
being asked of these people who might
have made a mistake that they didn't
even know that they were making um it
seems kind of on the order of public
flogging to
me anyone else wish yes representative
Perez I support this 100% I do not
believe that not knowing what the law is
is an excuse for not following the law
if I get stopped for speeding can I say
I didn't know that the speed limit was
60 and I was doing 80
so I support it right representative
organ um well in the speeding is usually
less than a $500 or, fine so just as I
just want to underline what that that
what Harvey said that this bill moves in
the wrong direction in that regard that
it's uh um um
that it's a uh you know $500 was already
an excessive penalty so A th000 is twice
as excessive and also the whole rigma
role about notor being forced to
apologize and notarizing your apology
and sending it certified mail um that's
which actually though is an
inconvenience for the person who also
receives the apology since uh you get
this scary looking slip of paper that
your mail carrier drops you have to go
to the Post Office Etc so that's um so I
just I just think the whole thing is
excessive and the amendment moves in the
wrong Direction and um of course I also
not really didn't quite understand what
the basic uh rationale for the bill was
either but so for all those reasons I
vote against amendment which makes a
bill that I didn't think was good and
makes it slightly worse so thank all
right anyone else wish be a
representative CH yeah just just adding
on to the sort of excessive nature I
think of this bill I just wanted to
clarify this is my reading of it uh
since the um the penalty is payable from
The Violator to the agreed individual
whose information was released it seems
like the the um if if if a library staff
person not even the librarian any
individual uh on staff if they were to
say accidentally mail out a list that
had some Librarians um uh had some some
list of people who had library cards
they would be paying up to $1,000 per
individual who's so this could run into
the hundreds of thousands of dollars for
an individual not the library but an
individual that seems excessive for what
we're talking
about representative bur then
representative Alexander yeah following
up that um I I join in those that feel
the purpose of the bill and the first
section is is fine but there troubling
aspects on the uh the penalty end one of
which is it's one thing for the state to
find find people uh for violating a
statute and then having that money go
into you know the general fund or
wherever it goes what this bill attempts
to do is use
legislation
to um accomplish what a civil suit would
do and it would replace if if my library
card was uh or library card status and I
do have a library card that was very old
um if my status is disclosed and I feel
like suing or speaking to the person I
can and I can sue for damages or
whatever and those damages could could
be shown uh reputational or
otherwise uh that's fine to have the
state do it for me um and turn the money
over to a private
individual uh is is heading I think in
in the wrong direction I'm also of
course and my Town's a small town we
have a very small Library we have I
think
one.5 people that are involved in it
they do the best they can uh they don't
get involved in politics at all uh at
least in their official capacity and as
representative tur suggests this is an
open-ended policy if a list goes out or
or or legislation that could amount to T
of thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars for this uh individual who if
they were acting in their
capacity as a town employee should more
properly be a uh a a tariff or penalty
that the town pays but this bill makes
it um uh on the back of the individual
uh staff member or librarian and frankly
in small towns I don't know about gof
town because it's a large town uh but in
small towns it's hard enough to get
volunteers to work at places like
libraries or work for a very small
amount of money or volunteer for boards
or this that and the other but to say if
you make a mistake while you're doing
your
job and you made a mistake uh and it's
going to cost you personally Untold
amount of money um that's going to make
it really hard to get people to work at
libraries thank you right representative
Alexander yeah very briefly thank you Mr
chair representative Burch paints such a
great picture of what a small town
library should look like um he you know
pictures he portrays his small town
library as one that doesn't make
political statements and doesn't um
isn't an activist library and I don't
think necessarily all libraries are like
that and so I while I appreciate that
his library is like that there are
others in the state that they're not so
this bill is a simple bill that makes it
so that public libraries do not violate
somebody's privacy and if they do it's
a$1 thousand, fine I don't understand um
why it why it's as contentious as it is
I think protecting people's privacy is
one of the
uh duties of our committee all right all
right representative Smith uh thank you
very much um I certainly agree that
protecting privacy is one of the
important roles of this committee and we
have several bills that we'll be voting
on today um that work to PR uh protect
privacy I'm not sure that this bill is
one to fall in that category we all know
and sometimes are amused by our
colleagues who come in there who in here
and have been upset by a decision that
was made in their local town I think of
one of our Representatives who came in
last year because he wanted to hold a
meeting and a particular facility said
no they wouldn't permit that meeting and
so he wanted us to um to have a bill my
feeling on that bill was what ought to
happen is he ought to figure out how to
talk with the people in his town to get
an
accommodation this bill is one of a
series that we have that we have had
before us and that we have treated
respectfully that came out of a
particular situation in a particular
town in which a Court ruled that in fact
the library had not done anything wrong
had not done anything political um but
still there is a lot of anger that town
had an election
yesterday and to vote for people to um
be library trusties and as I understand
it the winners in that election were
people who thought that they had respect
for the library and the way the library
was functioning and didn't need anything
else um I don't think we should use the
power and the um integrity of the J
Judiciary Committee to try to um appease
the anger of one or another whether it's
a person in on our committee who we
respect and love or whether it's a
person who's not in our committee in
respect to love this is over the toop
the fine is unbelievably inappropriate
the public um uh the public apology is
to totally irrelevant unless things have
come to the stage where we're going to
build um something in front of town hall
um build stocks in front of town hall
where we can periodically put people we
don't approve of in the stocks and I
don't think we're there yet I don't
think we should pass the Bill no matter
how much we like this moners all right
representative Horan if you have
something new I'm sorry R Manos were you
yes just in the oh hold on oh just
instance of full disclosure I realize I
actually have three library cards I'm
caring around with them one of them is
from a library located in another stat
it's not in a jurisdiction but I do have
not one I have cards from the Durham
public library and the UNH libraries and
by the way I think anybody in state so I
just want to say I'm not so I have
nothing to hide on this issue about okay
I do have I do confess to having library
cards all right representative Manos I
just wanted to add to the discussion
that there's um if there's a factual
dispute about whether there was explicit
consent um there's no due process in
this uh in this bill there's no
adjudication there's no process for
determining what the facts are and um I
oppose it for those reasons in addition
to the others all right any uh any other
comments so I guess I would what I would
say is I think I'm I intend to support
the amendment I you know I
I do I swallow a little hard about the
amount of the fine and the apology me
yeah but I I defer to what to the the
view of my colleagues in my caucus on
this and so I intend to support it um
all right so I guess the first thing is
a vote on the amendment I will do a roll
call vote on the amendment if anybody
wants it anybody I would like a roll
call vote all right so we'll have a roll
call vote on Amendment
32h to House Bill
666 so I'd ask the clerk to please call
the
rooll vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland yes
representative C yes representative
Smith no representative Corgan no
representative Burch
no representative Harvey no
representative Manos
no representative tur no representative
Rambo no representative bon no and
chairman Lynn
yes 10 Ys eight Nays right all right so
we're now on to
um now on to the main motion um of OTP
moved by representative Alexander
seconded by me does anyone else wish to
to speak to the main motion of
otpa seeing none I would ask the clerk
to call the role on uh the main motion
of otpa with representative Alexander's
Amendment Vice chairman Manion yes
representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrews yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes
representative C yes representative
Smith no representative Horgan no
representative bur no representative
Harvey no representative Manos
no representative t
no representative Rambo no
Representative berson
no and chairman Lynn yes 10 Ys eight
Nays representative Alexander it sounds
like you may be up again for I would
love to write this report thank you and
I I will do the the other all right and
representative Smith you'll write The
Minority Report yes I will all
right um
all right so that Tak 666
um see one hang on give me one
second
um um
all right uh next I'm going to uh take
this a little bit out of order um but I
think
um
um it's appropriate I'm going to turn to
hcr1 and I'm going to recognize myself
and I move to
retain um HCR 11 is there second second
all right so it's been moved by um
representative Lyn seconded by um
representative Manos and I
um I apologize uh and I would uh I just
speak very briefly um to this uh
resolution
um I I have to say I'm just going to say
candidly I
um there's a great deal in that
resolution that I am very sympathetic to
um in terms of separation of powers
issues um I think this is not an
appropriate time um for us to be issuing
a resolution like this where there is a
matter that the resolution deals with
that is um that is pending before um
another branch of government the the
Supreme Court so I think that the most
appropriate thing to do is for us to
retain this um for perhaps another
occasion when it might uh make more
sense and that's all I'll say about that
anyone else wish to be heard on hcr1 yes
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
I just want to clarify your intention
you want to retain it but not work on it
you just want to hold it for future
consideration well I you know perhaps
work on it I mean I you know if I if uh
you know have I sort of gone through
line by line and scrubbed every line to
see if I might change no I haven't done
that so to the extent that that could
there be some changes yes but but in but
I I you know I think you are also
correct that I think that timing is is
uh is very important and I think this is
not the appropriate time representative
Smith um yes I I agree with you Mr
chairman that this is not the
appropriate time for um this particular
uh HCR um I actually believe that there
is no time that is appropriate for this
and I believe that I have been elected
by my
constituents not by my caucus not by
party leadership but my constituents to
to carry out my
responsibilities which
include a respect for the constitution
of this state and a respect for the
importance of separation of powers so
that if I had an opportunity to vote on
the merits of this bill I would be
voting no and or in the vernacular itl
and I will therefore also be voting no
on um
retain uh clearly not because I then
want to have an A to pass motion thank
you right anyone else wish to be heard
representative Horan um two two other
well two practical considerations are is
first of all uh the rules of the other
body they need a two-thirds vote even to
consider an HCR so it's not even if this
even if we send it over there there's I
suppose we shouldn't speculate about
what some body would do but you know
there's more likely than not to not even
take this up but also we're going to one
way or another either pass a budget or a
continuing resolution before a retained
Bill hearing could be held and um that
will uh presumably uh I guess once again
maybe I shouldn't speculate even about
this body do but I think there's a very
high probability that it'll be similar
to past budgets so there'll be
controversy over it there'll be more uh
more court cases but it's probably not
going to settle the it's probably not
going to settle the objections of the
various Court decisions that have been
made over the years even though those
Curt decisions are based not just on the
state constitution but also on the
statute which I guess was passed 32
years ago and there's been we're in our
16th or 17th budget cycle since that
series of lawsuits started but any but
as a pract just as a practical matter uh
um we're probably going to pass a budget
which probably will not satisfy uh
satisfy those who brought the lawsuits
that were objecting to so all right
anyone else wish to be heard
representative McFarland well I
certainly concur with you Mr chairman
that the timing of this is is not ripe
uh at the moment I I also feel i' would
be doing my constituents a significant
disservice if I didn't work to amarate
the language so I'm supporting
retain representative
Burch thank you Mr chair
um I will vote against retaining because
I don't personally believe as suggested
by representative Smith that there will
ever be a time to pass a uh bill that is
is so disrespectful of another branch of
government that this is that in the very
first paragraph quoting the uh
constitution of the State of New
Hampshire the bill doesn't even fully
quote article 37 of part one uh in full
but leaves out the section that says as
consistent with that chain of connection
that binds the whole fabric of the
constitution in one indisoluble Bond of
unity and family Amity so um I will vote
against the motion to retain and should
that motion be defeated vote against the
bill all right anyone else wish to uh
anyone else wish to be heard
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
I I believe strongly very strongly in
the separation of powers and I think
it's completely inappropriate for the
legislature to be dictating to the um
judicial branch what the outcome of
cases or uh the providing guidance on
cases I think it's totally inappropriate
but in addition to that I would point
out that this is a house concurrent
resolution it has even if it were passed
it has no force of Law And for those two
reasons I will vote against retaining
and against the underlying Bill all
right anyone else wish to be heard all
right seeing none I would ask the clerk
to call the role the motion is to retain
hcr1 representative Manion I'm sorry
Vice chairman Manion yes representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland
yes repres representative C yes
representative Smith no representative
Horgan no representative Burch no
representative Harvey
no representative Manos
no representative tur no representative
Rambo no representative Bergeron
no and chairman Lynn yes 10 yays eight
Nays all right so
uh bill will be uh hdr1 will be
retained
um
uh just
low okay that's fine all right next um
I'm going to take up uh
HR um
s
um instructing the House of
Representatives to investigate whether
grounds exist to impeach Judge David
ruoff and the chair recognizes uh uh
representative Smith or her designate
for a motion
um thank you Mr chair for giving me the
honor of moving
itl on hr11
all right um I will uh so representative
Smith moves I will second that motion um
and representative Smith do you wish to
be uh to speak to your
motion I'm I'm hesitating because
clearly uh my mood today has gotten a
little
more
um insistent than is usually the case I
find that the bill having been
introduced is
even
um offensive to the
principles of uh the government of the
State of New Hampshire and
um to to threaten to impeach a
judge not for having his hand in the ti
not for inappropriate personal Behavior
not for anything else but because
someone doesn't like the
decision to me is even worse than
wanting to penalize an employee or a
volunteer in a library because a mistake
might have been made this is the
highest insult that I think we could be
part of and I do not want to part of
that insult anyone else wish to be heard
on this so I guess I I guess I would um
really Echo um representative Smith's uh
position you can agree or disagree with
judge Roth's decision and I have to say
candidly I have significant issues with
the decision but the
idea that um we are going to impeach a
judge for his decision is I think I
think it would be unprecedented I'm not
aware of anywhere maybe there is you
know somewhere in uh you know Alabama in
the 1870s or something they did
something like this but I can't imagine
it it is um it's
just candidly seems to me it's beyond
the pale um I have to say I you know all
cand I know judge rof he is a good
person he's a smart person he's a good
judge and whether he got this one right
or not provides absolutely no basis for
impeaching him um and so for those
reasons I intend to support the ITF
representative P pno thank you Mr chair
I agree with what you're saying however
I just want to clarify that um this
resolution is instructing the House of
Representatives to investigate whether
grounds exist for impeachment not the
actual impeachment no I I you know I I
agree with that I do agree but I think
it's clear from the L there's no
suggestion of anything else that judge
Rua did accept issue this decision so um
it would be you know what will if if we
were to actually have an investigation
what would it be I mean about whether he
issued the decision so I I I do agree
with you completely representative
pental but that's the way the the the
resolution is worded but that cand I
mean it just seems to me that's a smoke
screen because the only the only um
basis for for launching the
investigation is his decision so um any
anybody else wish to be
heard all right so the motion uh before
us is itl on uh house resolution 7 and I
ask the clerk to please call the role
Vice chairman Manion yes representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes
representative
cutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland yes
representative C yes representative
Smith yes representative Horgan yes
representative bur yes representative
Harvey
yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo
yes representative berson yes and
chairman Lynn yes 18 y zero
Nays any reason I can't go on the
consent
calendar Mr chairman do you want to
write or do you not uh yes if you don't
mind uh I would like to write the report
on I I'll write the majority report
um all right um can I just have one take
one
more
okay I just want to walk out
okay
good
sorry excuse me um I'm going to now turn
to House Bill
584 um and uh the chair recognizes
representative uh cutab for a
motion thank you I move uh a to pass
with Amendment 2025-the
966 each all right um hang on one
second
um all right is is there a second to uh
representative kab's motion I'll second
all right so move by uh representative
kutab seconded by representative uh
Manion is there representative Cav do
you wish to speak to your motion
briefly uh
so what this amendment does is it fixes
currently in the foreign Pharmacy
graduate statute it lists the world
directory of schools by the pharmacy
published in the world Health published
by the World Health
Organization in the bill um it had
changed for it had given an alternative
list for The Physician forign Medical
School graduate licensing but an
equivalent doesn't exist for the world
directory of Pharmacy schools published
by The Who so I think it's really
important that we ensure that this bill
won't interfere with the licensing of
our pharmacists who are
foreign um pharmacy school graduates and
so this amendment seeks to fix
that all
right all right anyone else wish to be
heard yes representative uh Smith um I'm
a little surp surprised that you that
this was called because um we just heard
it this morning and we haven't had a
chance to discuss it among ourselves but
um I
um whether I support the amendment or
not I think it's irrelevant because I
would strongly oppose the bill um and
would have liked to have had the
opportunity to discuss it among
ourselves right anyone else wish yes
representative H um well this amendment
first it doesn't incorporate the changes
that the prime sponsor recommended which
uh I mean I'm not particularly not
particularly don't particular strong
opinion one way or another about whether
that particular change was good it also
um although this would eventually be
caught by the clerk during the enrolled
Bill process it has a there's a typo um
there's it's I it's the possessive form
of the uh pronoun it it's or it's um
anyway it should say I it s and it says
it apostrophe s so it apostrophe s means
it is and so like what they meant was
it's the possessive form of of it so
that's um those are two things that are
missing from from uh from from this
amendment
so which any else I'm sorry
representative CH yeah I just want to
point out I mean a bill about uh groups
that have no jurisdiction within the
state clarifying that they have no
jurisdiction within the state there's
any number of of things that could fall
into similar categories and I feel like
opening the door to legislation like
this is uh wildly
inappropriate all right anyone else yes
representative Perez I just want to REM
lost it I just want to remind
everybody that a while ago the World
Health Organization and Joint un program
on HIV and AIDS recommended voluntary
male Medical male circumcisions a part
of as part of measures to prevent HIV
infections in Africa they found 23
million African men were circumcised and
then they found out that that absolutely
did absolutely nothing to prevent the
spread of AIDS
so I don't want that to happen to
us it's not going to happen um anyone
else wish to uh be heard on Amendment
um representative kab's Amendment
0966 seeing none um uh can we do this by
a show of hands or people want a roll
call show up hands is fine all right so
um on
Amendment 20250
966h uh can I ask all those in favor of
the amendment please uh raise your hand
who I'm wait a minute let me start again
everyone keep your hand keep your hand
up if you support the
amendment 11 12 13 13 all
right 13 and those opposed please raise
your hand
135 all right all right so um the
amendment passed so now I'm going to
recognize myself
and I'm
sorry no that's what I was going to say
I was going to do this you're talking
about representative Grangers Amendment
right yeah no I do so now I'm gonna um
actually if you're prepared to do it
I'll recognize you do you want to moove
uh representative Grangers Amendment
I move Amendment 2025
d683
H all right and I'll second that um
representative cutab do you wish to
speak to your
Amendment so this amendment merely
changes the part of regarding creating
and enforcing policies to enforcing
policies that are from the World Health
Organization un or the world economic
Forum all right
um all right anyone else wish to be
heard on uh Amendment
83h yes represent Manos thank you I'm
I'm just not
clear perhaps uh representative kab
could um explain a little further what
this amendment does I'm not I'm not
clear on what this
accomplishes thank you um so what this
amendment does is if you look on line
number 12 of the amendment in the
original Bill what it said was create
and enforce and now it's just says who
enforces instead of just instead of
including also create so it's just
changing it to
enforces yes representative Oregon well
it actually does a uh second thing so
the first R bills in only said enforces
policies but this also adds uh mandates
orders requirements tives or directives
of those organizations I guess
presumably if they if they were to issue
a mandate order requirement edct or
directive which was not however a change
of policy uh that would now be covered
by the bill as amended which they would
have been ex excluded from the original
bill so that it does do a second thing
so all right anyone else wish to be
heard on um Amendment 2025068322
12 all right
12 um and those opposed please raise
your
hand six 12 to six passes all
right all right so I I as I've looked
over the two amendments we've discussed
that is 0683 and 096 66h they do not
appear to me to in any way conflict so I
think that there's not a problem with
that and what I would do if if the bill
passes I would ask uh um our assistant
to ask the uh OS to prepare a
Consolidated house uh committee
amendment that will reflect that so I
think we're now on to the main Bill uh
House Bill four 584 as amended by both
of those amendments um and
representative kutab do you move or to
pass as amended with the two of them I
will or I'm sorry representative man yes
I move off to pass as amended on House
Bill 8 584 all right and I second that
um all right uh anyone wish to be heard
any further on the yes representative uh
bur so what we have here is
legislation based on
something that
suggests that first suggests that these
particular
organizations have
ever issued an enforcable mandate on the
people citizens of the Granite State to
my knowledge that has never happened in
the history of these
organizations or the history of New
Hampshire we
have no knowledge
whatsoever that any of these
bodies ever
will issue some kind of mandate on the
good folks of our state nor would such a
mandate if dreamed up by any of these
organizations have any effect of force
or law in our state so it would not be
worth the paper it's written on if some
bureaucrat somewhere in Zurich or uh
upper east side of New York I think
that's where the UN is um decided to
write some sheet of paper so because
this
bill literally does not change any past
practice will not change any any future
practice um I see no reason that we
should enact this
legislation sorry representative Perez I
am very sure that the 23 million African
men never thought it would happen to
them
either right any anyone else wish to be
heard on uh the the vote on the main
bill with the uh two Amendment seeing
none I would ask the clerk to call the
role on aop pass uh on uh HB 584 as with
the two amendments that we've previously
voted
on Vice chairman Manion yes
representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland yes
representative C yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative Burch no representative
Harvey no representative Manos no
representative tur no representative
Rambo no and representative berson
no and chairman Lynn yes 10 y eight Nays
right and representative Manion could I
ask you to write the report yes for the
majority and will there be a minority
yes will
definely forward uh but I think
representative Smith has already done
that oh
okay all right that will not be on
consent I will not be on consent that's
for sure all right so we're done 584 all
right um
hang on one second
uh
um all right I think
um this is uh
yeah yeah yeah no so I'm GNA take no I'm
G to take a uh I'm going to recess the
executive session now for let's say uh
uh 30 minutes um so that people can uh
do whatever they need to do including
eating lunch or other things and also to
have uh if some people need to C us they
can C us um thank you and thank you
representative C for uh being here I
know you uh you have this has been a an
inconvenience for you and I appreciate
it very much thank
you
e
e e
have we got everybody back uh oh not
quite
people coming back
all right so I'm going to uh reconvene
the executive session uh of the
Judiciary Committee um and I'm going to
uh as the next bill take up to exec uh
is HB
580 FN and the chair recognizes
representative Smith or her design for a
motion Mr chair on 580 I recommend
retain is there a second for that all
right hang on so it's
moved by representative Smith seconded
by representative
Romo all right uh representative Smith
do you wish to speak to your
motion I think the issues that are
raised in this bill are very
serious I think that
the structure of the Bill does
not
completely address those
issues um and I believe that if the
committee takes
seriously
um it's its role and we'll spend some
time trying
to improve the bill we could end up with
a product that meets
majority a agreement all right anyone
else wish to be heard on uh the motion
to retain on House Bill
580 right so I could say I basically I'm
I'm in I'm in agreement with
representative Smith I you know I have I
had I have at least one idea as I
mentioned earlier about a possible
resolution that may or may not s be you
know something that would draw majority
support from everybody on the committee
but um it's something I mean that's that
demonstrates to me that it's least it's
at least worth uh uh thinking about so
I'm I would support the uh motion to
retain um anyone else wish to be heard
on uh the motion to retain on House Bill
580 all right seeing none I'd ask the
clerk to call the role please uh the
motion is to retain Vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander
representative
trip representative Andrew yes
representative kutab yes representative
Perez yes uh clerk votes yes
representative McFarland
yes representative C
yes representative Smith
yes representative Horgan
yes representative
Burch
yes representative Harvey yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes
representative berson yes thank you and
chairman Lynn
yes 18 y zero
Nays all right um so we don't need a
report on that that takes care of
580 um next um I'm going to take up um
House Bill uh
132 and uh the chair uh recognizes uh
representative
CA thank you chairman Lynn I move ought
to pass with Amendment
2025-the
it by representative Alexander uh
representative kutab do you wish to
speak to your motion yes thank you
chairman Lynn this
Amendment while while we heard a lot
of testimony about how kind of archaic
this this statute is um and that we're
not jailing
people I I think most of us can agree we
should remove that part out if we're not
we're not doing it we wouldn't want it
to actually happen and so that whole
chunk of the bill has all been removed
we're no longer jailing people however
this has been a useful tool particularly
in smaller towns when when a relative is
capable of providing this means so
that the neighbors aren't aren't having
to pick up the tab for something that
the family could pay for but this is
also making sure that Aid to the person
who's otherwise eligible for assistance
under this chapter shall not be withheld
due to the failure of a legally liable
relative to either respond or provide
the aid and I think that is really
important we don't want to have people
that need the aid but can't get in touch
with a a relative not being able to get
the aid however at the same time we want
to make sure if somebody is is able to
provide it
that they are providing it so for that
reason I think it's important to amend
the bill with this amendment thank you
all right anyone else wish to be heard
on uh we're talking actually now about
the amendment 2025
0927 to House Bill 132 anyone else wish
to be heard yes oh yes representative
bur uh so I'd like to ask uh if I may a
clarification just to make sure I
understand the
amendment um the idea of this bill as
amended uh would be that the town or
city would still provide the aid but
that they could then sue any of the
named relatives for the money uh go
through their finances subpoena their
financial records and tax forms and do
all the rest to see if they could have
sufficient means to pay is that the idea
of this bill
Amendment thank you for the question so
currently they are able to do all of
that but they're not really doing all of
that and if they find that you are able
and you're just not doing it they can
jail you right now for at least 60 days
but up to 90 days and so this is
removing that jail piece out so I think
it is important to remove that piece out
um I do think they they the welfare
officer made it pretty clear that
they're not going through the process of
doing all of this leg work but if
somebody does come in and says yeah I'm
able to help that family member out
they're having that family member help
out but they're not they're not
subpoenaing people so I just I it's not
happening now I don't see
it I don't necessarily see it happening
in the future um but I do think that
it's important that currently they're
able to work together to try and get the
relatives to help out if they're able to
if we repealed this all together then
there would be nothing at all you know
there would be no reason that a relative
would even try it or or necessarily want
to help if they don't have to because
why pay money that you don't have to pay
right no anyone else wish I mean you'd
hope somebody doesn't think that way but
anyone else wish to be heard uh on this
yes representative Bon I know you've
probably already dealt with this but I I
was uncomfortable with the word poor
just for that reason but you've had more
experience than I have
so it just says that on the bill and
I've noticed it last time and it kind of
bothered me a little bit but the I don't
know about the word
poor but you know if everybody's happy
with it
then may I so that's that's existing in
the current statute I didn't change that
piece in there um
I suppose it could be changed
to um to say you know in poverty you
know poverty I think but I I you know
it's already in there this
statute was I you know pretty old it
came up in the 1900s when it was first
kind of put in so I think you know that
was just a term that was used at that
time and I didn't go through uh changing
that language right other question
anyone else wish to be heard so I I
guess um you know what I what I would
say is I think first of all I think that
representative kab's amendment makes
makes this law much better um than the
original version and my my sense and I
don't know whether representative Burch
would agree with me on this or not I
think and I I think this maybe goes to
what a little bit about your the
question you're asking I think
that there could be in some
circumstances a real question as to the
constitutionality of this if the if for
example the state uh or town were trying
to hold someone responsible
for uh providing uh support or something
for you know an adult child who didn't
live in the home and it was was uh was
on their own and maybe seriously
estrange from the parents or whatever I
don't know about that I whether that
would be whether there be some
constitutional issue with that or not
but I think the other side of that
argument is that if that if such a
person is not held liable then the
burden falls on the on the entire town
and that's a legitimate interest too I
guess what I guess what I would say is
it seems to me that this this statute
has been on the books for a long time it
doesn't appear from the evidence we
heard that it's being abused towns are
handling it you know are exercising
their discretion appropriately it seems
to me this by taking out the language of
jail that seems it to me it softens it
even further and so what I would say
is excuse me I would support this and my
sense would be if there are some
circumstances in which you know it would
be really unfair to the point of being
uncon constitutional for for a town to
try to collect from somebody then that
is something that's a time for that to
be challenged and the court would would
rule that way but but I don't think that
that's a reason not to have this Statute
in in this amended form on the books
because I think it does serve some
useful purpose so I intend to support
the amendment and and vote for it any
representative
trip having been a town counselor and
having had to deal with this you know I
uh I am probably going to vote no
because uh you know it appears that this
would make the towns and cities liable
for all the homeless people that are in
there uh
uh that's already in a statute that's
already in statute that part isn't that
part isn't changing the part that's
changing about it is just the part
that's saying that um
they already have to provide it but it's
saying that if you if the if they can't
get a hold of the the relative or if the
relative refuses to provide it that they
do still have to that the town does
still have to provide it right now if
you can't get a hold of the relative
technically the town could just refuse
to provide the aid and that has
become problematic in some towns because
some relatives just don't respond
although the majority of the towns are
just giving the a anyhow but that that
liability already exists in the current
statute with pretty pretty similar
language to this well I agree with you
on that the the issue that I have is
that uh this simply
clarifies that uh the towns are are
responsible for the homeless people that
reside in it and it'll probably be
a people be taking
much more advantage of this thank you
right any any other anyone else want to
be heard all right so we're we're we're
on the amendment 0927 H and uh anybody
uh want to can I do this by a show of
hands or does anybody want a roll
call all right so I'll do it by a show
of hands can I ask all those who are in
favor of amendment 2025 927 0927 H2
House Bill 132 FN please raise your hand
17 all right and and representative trip
is opposed all right no that's fine um
17 all right now we're on to uh the main
motion um representative Cav you move
otpa is that
correct yes and is that seconded
representative Alexander seconded by
representative of Alexander all right
anyone have anything further they want
to say on the on the uh bill as amended
can I bring up one
thing yes representative kutab and then
representative bur so I just um to get
back to what rep rep trip was mentioning
what it currently says in the statute is
if a poor person has no relation of
sufficient ability the town or city in
which he resides shall be reliable for
his support so it's already in current
statute that they are that the town is
liable representative
bur thank you I I intend to vote against
this uh oot oh we have
OTP uh which is to repeat uh as amended
right as amended yes so I intend to vote
against that
um to follow up what the representative
just said it seems to me the obligation
on the town first would have to be to
find out if any relative could pay and
then pay I if there is no such relative
so as I understand this bill now if
there's a any poor person uh within the
town the state the town would then have
to start an
investigation before paying any support
to that
person would have to go then investigate
the father mother stepfather father
stepmother son daughter husband or wife
to determine and only if they can't then
the if then there's no relation of
sufficient ability then the town or city
and this is lines 21 and 22 shall be
liable for their support so the order
that it's done seems to be set out in
the statute that first you find out if
somebody else can do it and only then
will the state have or the town have an
obligation to step forward I don't like
that idea if I'm correct in it and the
second part is again I live in a small
town pretty much everybody knows
everybody and what we have here is a
situation of unbridled
discretion on the town or the uh the the
the overseer the poor or whatever it's
called in any particular town and I
think our town still calls it that um
that that overseer the poor uh has no
boundaries on discretion so he or she is
sitting in their office and somebody
comes in and the overseer of the poor
says oh I know that family you know I'm
not going to bother collecting or I know
that family I'm going to go investigate
them more thoroughly and check into
their their finances of all the
relatives so it's unbridled discretion
on behalf of this town
official uh as to who might be subject
to this Recruitment and who not I don't
think
that's there's
no no process here to assure that it's
being done fairly and uh equitably
especially in the small towns in
Manchester or nashille or conquer that
may not be a problem where people are
more Anonymous but in small towns and I
represent three of them it's a it's a
different issue thank you representative
couta thank you and thank you for their
question so um right now what's
currently on the books is that they have
to do what you you mentioned with
finding out if they're able and it
should they find out if they're able
then if they refuse to do it the be
ordered by the county commissioner
selectman or overseer public welfare and
if they don't do it then they'll be
summons to appear before court and if
after a hearing it's found that the
alleged person is in need of assistance
and that the relative is able to render
it then the court will enter a decree
accordingly to demand that the person
provide this and if they don't then
they'll be jailed so I think what's
currently on the books is a lot more
um but this so this what this is saying
is that if the if the person doesn't
answer or refuses to say if they can
provide it or not the the town is still
going to provide it if we don't have
this at all then the town is not you
know
not perhaps not going to provide any Aid
to
anybody all right anyone else um wish to
be
heard yes representative ber if you
don't mind I'd like to ask a sort of a
general question after we pass bills
like that do we ever get data or do we
only get data if we review the bill
again or you know from the outside folks
like how's this going you know that kind
of
I well it sort of depends and I guess
you know we did get I think we got some
information at the hearing um anyone
else wish to representative trip so I
guess that's a no I have a question of
Representative katab we know it's a uh
was there a reason that you removed the
County Commissioners from the people
that were
responsible yes so I did talk to the uh
several of the County Commissioners and
none of them had ever done this before
it was all going through
the welfare administrator they were they
were never doing anything like this the
ones that I that I spoke with thank you
right representative Horgan another
related question um
what about the what if the this is
probably a fairly rare thing but what
about the case where the uh person lives
in a
unincorporated unincorporated place in
which case then the County Commissioners
basically serve as the uh select board
for that portion of the county that's
not part of an incorporated town so of
which
there's one town in Carol County and
several which has some population then
there's one Township in Carol County and
then there's in Coos County one that's
uninhabited in Grafton too
but I I believe overall we have one
welfare administrator for the state who
came here to testify before us and so he
assists the cities and towns with this
type of a thing so I think they would
even if they're an unincorporated place
they would still be able to use that
paid um administrator from the state
okay sure yep sounds all right any any
further uh comment so I I the only
comment I would make in response to
representative Burch um
is you know I I mean you you know your
your scenario about like they're going
to
investigate somebody that might be
potentially liable
and and you know do Discovery and all
that I mean I it seems to me that there
was no evidence to suggest that that
kind of thing had happened um with with
the existing law which is more much
considerably more honorous carrying the
potential of jail uh than the proposed
amendment
so you know theoretically could that
happen I suppose it's possible but it
seems to me that it it's no more likely
to happen with with this amendment than
it is under existing law and it seems
like it doesn't happen so I I think that
I'm I'm sort of satisfied with
that representative Burch uh
respectfully it'll never happen if we
defeat the otpa in vote itl then we
don't have to worry about whether it'll
happen or not because it won't thank you
all right any further comment all right
so we we've already voted on the
amendment 17 to1 to pass it this is now
a motion of vote on the main bill with
the amendment otpa so I'd ask the clerk
to please call the
rule Vice chairman Manion
yes representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab
yes representative Perez yes clerk votes
yes representative McFarland yes
representative C yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative bur no representative
Paige oh sorry representative Harvey
no representative Manos
yes was that a
yes representative
tur yes
right representative Rambo
no representative berson yes
and chairman Lynn
yes 13 Ys five
Nays all right um uh representative
kutab can I ask you to write the
majority report i' we Havey to right now
will there be a Minority
Report sure no somebody else want to
write
it have to have
you a
moment all right I'll skip it all right
no Minority Report okay minority
I all right uh this is a regular
calendar yeah um all right um
all right next um so that takes care of
132 next
um I'm going to
uh I'm going to uh re I'm going to turn
to uh House Bill 188 and I'm going to
recognize myself and I move uh to pass
House Bill uh 88 is there a second I
second that seconded moved by myself
seconded by representative Alexander and
so what I what I'm I'm going to this is
a little
bit maybe a little bit unusual but I'm
not I know you have an amendment
representative Manos I'm I'm not
inclined to take up that Amendment but I
but I do want to give you an opportunity
to just tell as I understand it the
amendment changes the Superior Court to
the Circuit Court so
I in the interest of sort of having a
discussion let tell us why you think
that well Mr Mr chair to be fair you
have to entertain an amendment if it's
not to pass motion she can move her
Amendment if she
wants yes I do want she she can call for
a vote on the amendment I see I see what
you're saying okay okay all right so all
right so I guess then we'll I'll I'll
recognize you then do you you move you
move
Amendment uh uh o 0921 h 0921 all right
um very briefly Mr chair thank you first
of all is there a second for that oh
excuse me I'll second all right sorry so
mve by uh representative Manos seconded
by representative
Perez
uh go ahead representative Manos thank
you Mr chair very briefly um my
Amendment does um
align the the misdemeanor offense here
both criminal and uh the criminal
offense of misdemeanor with it being in
the Circuit Court um so that's what it
does it also takes out all the
references to committees subcommittees
joint
committies um I'm not sure that OS
drafted this in a way that um we can
easily see that but it does do that
um and so those are the two
uh changes that it makes to the
underlying
Bill I've got
one can I speak to that as
well uh so you want you're speaking to
representative Manos amend yes yes go
ahead
please uh so um I just circulated around
another amendment which is not what
we're talking about at the moment um
these were supposed to be two separate
amendments but um
representative Manos Incorporated mine
into hers um so I just kind of wanted to
make it clear that um there are two
separate Concepts on the table one of
them related to The Courts one of them
related to some extraneous language that
was included about other entities um
that I I believe from from your
testimony Mr chair might have been
Incorporated from federal language but
that those entities do not have the
ability to make um um or to issue
subpoenas so I I just take I took those
pieces out to clear up the language so
if you favor um representative Manos is
I I did I did check and it looks like
it's her her amendment is the same as
what would be there um plus the the
change in the courts and if if that does
not go then I might speak to my
men all right anyone else wish to be
heard all right so I guess what I would
I I guess what I say is I have two
things on that
first with regard to which
court I as I think I mentioned at the
hearing I deliberately chose the
superior court
because it's a constitutional Court um
it seems to me that this this would be
the kind of proceeding that ought to go
to the superior court if you're going to
you know if you're you're if the
legislature asking the the judicial
branch to find somebody in contempt send
them potentially find them guilty of a
crime or send them to uh uh send them
potentially to jail until they comply it
seems to me that this um is the kind of
thing um that ought to go to the
Constitutional trial court not the
Circuit Court U more importantly to the
extent that this calls for um the
issuance of an injunction
uh to compel somebody to comply on pain
of being held in contempt uh generally
the superior the the uh Circuit Court
doesn't have Equity jurisdiction to
issue injunctions now it true that in
marital cases and something like that
they do issue injunctions so it's you
know it's not it's not an absolute hard
and fast rule but it seems to me that um
allowing this to go to the circuit Court
um the other thing would be and
especially if it's a criminal case
there's a it's a misdemeanor that the
state could charge it as a Class A
misdemeanor which would mean there would
be a right to a jury trial the Circuit
Court doesn't do jury trials so for all
of those reasons I think the having this
proceeding in the in the superior court
is the is the right thing to do with
regard to the
language
about the you know joint committees and
things like that I think that it's
important to keep that language in there
because
um
the the way it's worded in the original
bill um I I think the important language
there is comply with a subpoena duly
issued and served so all of that means
that whatever the entity whether it's a
house committee or a senate committee or
a joint committee um and those are the
three I think that are covered by the
language of the original Bill those
committees would have to have the author
have been granted by rule the authority
to issue subpoenas so I don't think I
don't think that that language is
extraneous I I did take it from the uh
from the federal uh from the federal uh
statute but I think that that could
easily apply I mean the seems to me
the house and the Senate by rule could
authorize a joint committee to conduct
an investigation and give that joint
committee subpoena power so
representative
tur yeah just just on that part and just
to explain a a little bit further um I
did look at the rules of both the house
and the Senate they're separate rule
sets there's no Provisions in either one
of them for referring to the other body
um and uh the the power to issue it is
not granted to the Committees it's only
granted to the uh leader of either of
those bodies and so I feel like leaving
that language in there suggests although
obviously there'd be no way to
operationalize that language it seems to
suggest that there is the authority and
I believe that's what started this whole
question to begin with last year was was
a committee sort of asserting the
ability to to issue a subpoena that they
were not authorized to do so you know I
I I hope you don't again be it through
this amendment or maybe through through
my second amendment if not uh agree that
that taking it out would be cleaner than
leaving it in because whatever house
rules and they can change as long as we
say duly authorized we're incorporating
both bodies rules without having to
potentially run into conflicts in the
future true
all right uh representative Manos yeahor
representative Mana
not so my understanding or this is my
interpretation of that the subpoena is
being issued and served by either house
like the rules say the purpose of it is
under an inquiry before either the whole
house or any joint committee established
by a joint or concurrent resolution of
the two houses it just covers the areas
of where the subpoena is where the
inquiry is coming from a committee or a
joint committee it doesn't change the
fact that the subpoena is coming from
the house the speaker of the house like
the rules say so I I I see it as just
the opposite of what you're saying this
is just telling you where the inquiry is
coming from and the only person that can
issue it and serve it is the house of
the general court either house being the
speaker or the or the
president all I'll say is it you know
the rules change with each with each
house session so I think it's it's
cleaner not to have it but understand
what you're saying yeah see I guess I
what I think my concern is I think it's
actually cleaner to leave it to have it
in there because it covers then all
situations I mean if you I would I would
not want to
have potentially a situation suppose
that the house and the Senate decided in
some year that they were going to
authorize a joint um investigation to be
conducted by by the two bodies um and um
they were going to um they were going to
authorize that body that that joint
committee to to have the power of
issuing subpoenas I would not I think
under the language of the bill as I
drafted it that would that would then be
a duly authorized issued subpoena but
I'm not sure that it would be under I
mean at least an argument could be made
well um maybe that's not one that's
that's authorized under your language
that's that's my only concern so that's
why I think the language the broader
language um and as I said I with regard
to the Circuit or Superior Court I think
I've already stated my reasons so I I
guess representative tur
should does
your does representative
Manos uh Amendment Encompass the things
that I mean is it does it Encompass your
Amendment do we have to vote separately
on both of them or just just
representative Manos well if if if if
you don't support representative Manos
is amendment then I would wonder if you
would consider mine without the change
in the court system but okay um
otherwise I did a quick read and um and
I did send you a mark send everyone a
mark up by email showing what I took out
but um I I believe represent Manos is uh
Amendment incorporates mine as well all
right well so let's then let's see where
let's see where we go on the Manos
Amendment and then if that if that fails
I'll turn to yours um so I I uh just to
sum up I plan to vote against the Manos
Amendment for the reasons I've I've just
stated anyone else have anything they
want to say all right so the motion is
on um representative uh
Manos um Amendment which is uh 09
21h um and I uh do we need anybody want
a roll call or can we do this by uh show
of hands all right so all those in favor
of Representative Manos uh
Amendment uh 0921 h u please raise your
hand three four all right hang
on um
all right and all those uh oppos to
representative Manos Amendment please
raise your
hand
one 10 11 11 all right 4 to 11 so the
amendment
fails wa oh somebody wait somebody
didn't somebody didn't
vote oh wait a minute oh wait a minute
we have let's try again all those in
favor of Representative May Amendment
please raise your hand one
two 3 four all right now all those
opposed to representative maners
Amendment please raise your hand one two
three
four 14 all right i' I've learned to
count now four 14 to four the amendment
fails all right let me turn then to uh
hang on this is
0921 recogniz yeah I no I recognize
representative tur and do you want to
have a speak to anything further you
want to say about your Amendment yes to
introduce it yeah I just just to
introduce it it's 20250
944 H and I think I've said all I uh can
about why all right is there a second
for representative tur's uh
motion all right move by uh excuse me
representative uh tur seconded by
representative uh
Manos um all right anyone else wish to
uh speak to uh representative tur
Amendment
yeah I mean I think it it basically I
think I I do think I understand what it
what it does so um all right and for the
um for the reason I've said it before I
would I I I think that the language
should stay as in the original bill for
the reasons I've stated anyone else want
to speak on um representative tur's
Amendment all right then can I ask for a
show of hands all of those in favor of
of a representative tourers Amendment
0944 please raise your
hand two three
four five six seven all
right seven and those opposed to
representative ter Amendment please
raise your
hand 10 wait minute we got if the number
was not right I raised my hand late in
favor all right wa minut let let me
start again all those in favor of
Representative tur Amendment please
raise your hand no in flavor of
Representative tur Amendment
one 2 3
4 five 6 7 8 all right eight sorry all
right now all those opposed to
representative terror's Amendment please
raise your hand two three four five six
seven eight n 10 all right 8 to 10 the
amendment fails the all right now we're
back to the main motion I would move a
pass on um HB 188 as uh drafted is there
a second seconded by representative
Alexander
right
second all right anybody have anything
else they want to say
on uh the motion of
OTP uh on
188 seeing none I ask the clerk to call
the role
please Vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland
yes representative C
yes representative Smith
yes representative Horgan
yes representative bur yes
representative Harvey
yes representative Manos
yes representative tur yes
representative Rambo
yes representative berson yes thank
you and chairman Lynn yes 18 Ys zero
Nays all right um can that go on
consent all right consent and I'll write
the
report all
right that takes care of who's writing
the report I'm I'm
writing
um next next um I'd like to turn to um
hang on one second I just want to keep
all this paperwork in in order
here I have my Bible
here all right next I'm going to turn to
uh house bill um
um relative to class action settlements
and
uh consent decrees and I'm going to
recognize myself and move uh ought to
pass is there a second representative
kab I
second um hang
on
um
687 hang on while I find
this7 188
um so I I uh basically it what this bill
provides is that um class action uh if
there's if there's money that's not
um to be distributed to class members um
then it then it sheets to uh the state
and that the doctrine of s prey shall
not apply to allow uh courts
to allow monies that are not distributed
to class members to
be diverted and I know that might some
people might say maybe diverted is the
wrong word but change to another purpose
um I think that um
um makes sense the bill also would would
provide that um attorney fees Awards in
in uh consent
decrees um are limited to that as
provided in The lafy Matrix and if the
bill was was limited to saying that I
would have some problems with it but it
says unless otherwise unless the court
otherwise determined so the court would
have discretion to to you know find that
some other method of awarding attorney's
fees was appropriate and I think as long
as the court has that discretion I don't
have any problem with that so for those
reasons I uh I would support the bill I
intend to vote um in favor anyone else
wish to be heard on uh
687 representative
bur thank you Mr
chair
what troubles me about this bill
is I get that mail from time to time
that there's a class action filed and
please return the proper forms and you
might get your $4 and 23 cents out of
the class action I'm sure most of us
have gotten those these tend to be
Nationwide uh
multi-jurisdictional
lawsuits um often large corporations
have done something wrong and they need
to refund some or they're being sued
they might have to refund some money um
it makes little sense to
me for New Hampshire to create its
own
system for distribution of money and the
like which may be in conflict with
what's happening in maybe 49 or or
however many states are being fected by
this class action suit so all of a
sudden
um whoever is disgorging this money
whether it's the court somewhere in
Omaha or somewhere else uh wherever
they're dis gorging it is going to have
to pay attention to HB
separately
um and and the like and I know it's just
talking about money that it's otherwise
not
distributed but this might work well to
me in um in class action that's solely
New Hampshire but I don't see maybe I've
just missed it that um this applies to
all class actions that affect the
citizens of New Hampshire and I just
don't see it's it's uh it's
workable right anyone else wish to be
heard
so I guess I think my my response to
that representative ber it seems to me
that it would it would only apply to
class actions that New Hampshire has
jurisdiction over and I would it would
seem to me that if there was a if there
was a nationwide class action let's say
it was in federal court or in the court
of some other state I would assume that
the that the uh how proceeds should be
distributed would be determined by the
court that state or the federal court
and New Hampshire wouldn't have any
jurisdiction
so that that's the way I would interpr
it would be nice if it said
it well
I I I I don't think it I'm not I'm not
sure that if it does that by not saying
it that would give New Hampshire some
jurisdiction where it wouldn't otherwise
have jurisdiction so anyone yes
representative H it gives no definition
of what the lafy Matrix is and I never
heard of it until this bill came along
but it's apparently there are several
different versions of it and there's
other matrices used in other uh in other
jurisdictions apparently only originated
in the Washington in the baltim
Washington DC Baltimore metro area so
that's uh that seems like a pretty
glaring weakness with the builder relies
on something that um it doesn't say
exactly what it is
so yeah uh yes representative Burch if I
could just go a little further on that
uh yes The Laffy Matrix has been
rejected by numerous numerous numerous
courts and there's even a laughly matrix
to which has also been rejected by
numerous federal courts though I think
the Baltimore Washington jurisdiction
around there is one that still does it
why we would be promoting or suggesting
or having that as the option of first
course I don't know given how rejected
it's been
so I I guess my my only response to that
would be if if as I said before if if
the if there wasn't the unless say
language in there I might be concerned
about that but since the uh New
Hampshire courts I think are fully
capable of determining whether you know
it makes sense in a particular case or
not I assume they would do
that so anyway any anybody have anything
further they want to say on um HB 687
I'm seeing none um I the motion is uh o
OTP on 687 and I'd ask the clerk to
please call the
role Vice chairman Manion yes
representative Alexander representative
trip yes representative Andrews yes
representative kutab yes representative
Perez yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes representative
yes representative Smith representative
Horgan no representative Burch no
representative Harvey
no representative Manos
no representative tur
no representative Rambo
no Representative berson no
thanks no thank you and represent
chairman Lynn yes 10 y 8 n
um I'll write the uh main report who
want is it going to be a Minority
Report I'm not doing I can tell you that
busy anybody want to write a Minority
Report you don't have to you don't have
to but all right I'll write one all
right
bir yes yes minority it's going to be
short
right all right um so that takes care of
um next I'm going to turn to uh
on House Bill
uh
722 and the chair recognizes represent
mcfar thank you Mr chairman I move uh
that we adopt the
amendment
965h so you move the bill and you move
this amendment pass with Amendment all
right is there a second for
this all right second it move by uh
representative McFarland seconded by
representative
Alexander um and representative
McFarland do you wish to speak to uh the
amendment yes I would be pleased to so
the amendment which um I know you have
in front of you uh I have provided one
page that is a sample disclaimer in 24o
font which I'll come back to um and then
I've provided you with the amendment uh
this addresses I I believe the vast
majority of the concerns that had been
expressed
uh relative to the the the prime
sponsor's original language um and so I
what I would talk about is is really
just let's focus on the amended bill um
New Hampshire students deserve
transparency when making one of the
biggest financial decisions of their
lives investing in a college degree is
something that comes with significant
costs and
risks uh and
indeed opportunity costs that that are
lost versus uh what else they could be
getting up to and so when we examine the
circumstances we see that prospective
students um are
often unaware
or uh regretful about the true costs and
and those financial risks of higher
education and so what we need to do is
we need to make sure that we're giving
them the cont text that we're giving
them enough
information that they can make a free
market decision as to whether they want
to enter into uh that degree program um
and and make sure that they understand
uh
what they're putting themselves down for
and so the the uh the amended
bill um it
requires either that the educational
institution provides certain disclosure
es
or that if the educational institution
does not wish to do
that that they get the prospective
student upon matriculation to sign off
on a
disclaimer that's it right if if I am a
company wanting to engage in the
business of higher education and I say
well I don't believe I should be
regulated this heavily then you just
need to get the student along with
signing the other 37 pie of paper when
they sign up to sign that piece of paper
as well but if you do want to offer your
prospective
students some strong information that
may be helpful to them in the
marketplace this bill lays out a number
of of items that we would like to see in
there and in particular what it does is
it helps them
understand how much they are likely to
make whether they're likely to graduate
whether they're likely to be
successful uh and gives them the
opportunity to contemplate options and
it also identifies to them something
that I've come across plenty of students
that still to this day don't understand
and that is that with the changes in
federal law uh that we have seen uh a
lot of these student loans are not
dischargeable in bankruptcy so either
way whether the educational institution
chooses to provide the information or
whether they don't uh that fact Act is
going to become abundantly clear to the
the student who's signing up um so I
think beyond that I would be happy to
answer any questions but I I just
encourage you to move or to pass all
right qu representative Smith and then
representative Horton thank you I do
have a few questions until the chair
stops me um I notice um representative
um that all this refers to the students
does any of it refer to the people who
in fact are signing the checks which is
most
likely uh the
parents so first off the answer is it
does refer to the students right the the
purpose of this bill is less about
presenting a cause of action um for
whether it's students or whomever uh
than Travis's original bill was um this
bill is now uh about transparency and
disclosure so at one level you could say
that that that aspect of it is is less
material um but I would also say that uh
at the end of the day uh entering into a
degree program is a decision that should
be made on an informed basis by the
student themselves and they should not
be being pushed into it uh by anyone
including um their parents or the
guardians or whoever may be paying their
bills and I think when you look at the
the entrepreneurship that we want to
encourage in this country what you see a
lot of times with college graduates is
you see uh grads who are having on a
regular you know recurring monthly basis
to pay a certain nut to pay off their
loans and are not able to uh just stop
doing that so that they can contemplate
starting up a small business or doing
something else entrepreneurial um so I
think to your question representative
Smith I would suggest that the most
important person in that decision is the
student themselves could I follow up yes
there's nothing that I said that
didn't recognize that but when you're
talking about financial matters the
writing of the check I believe is rather
important and the implications of that I
I'm curious that you don't seem to think
that that the check writers should have
that information that it should only be
the student oh I see okay so so two
quick responses to that because I think
it breaks down in two parts right one is
as far as the information goes they
would have that if if the educational
institution chooses to comply with the
disclosure requirements in here then
that includes publishing it on a website
for for anyone to see not just for the
prospective students so that's the first
part of the answer I think the second
part of the answer is that to the extent
that there's a desire to go after them
um in court uh the the fact that the
parents for example may have paid for
the degree they are paying for that on
behalf of the student for the benefit of
the student and it's still the student
who is harmed if they are going through
a degree program that does not actually
uh deliver on the Promises they could I
ask one more and then I'll in the field
for at least a while
um uh of the let's just think about the
people who are the students who are in
college
today and have uh decided on a major a
focus of their college education
today and are pursuing that at the cost
that they
incur of those students who are in
college today and have chosen what they
want
to uh specialize in
how many of those students in five years
will find that those
particular folky the plural of focus in
this case um uh are still relevant or
that that particular
Focus has gone the way of the Platypus
and now they're doing something
else so I don't have quantitative
statistics on that in front of me but I
would say to you anecdotally that first
of all um the what we see in the
marketplace is
typically that yes people may end up
pursuing a course of employment which is
not 100% align to their their chosen
major however I think we can more
commonly see patterns
in uh who is successful in the
marketplace in in the workplace uh and
what their major is and so uh you know I
I think we can certainly anticipate that
there are going to be different outcomes
for a a similar quality student pursuing
an underboard basket weaving degree than
pursuing uh let's say uh a a law degree
or a medicine
degree could I just ask one more and
that is is the sole purpose of higher
education vocational training or are
there any other benefits great question
I mean the answer is really easy
absolutely not but if you are somebody
who is contemplating higher education
for other purposes than to provide for
yourself you are perfectly at Liberty to
then either look at the disclosed
information and ignore it or sign the
disclos claer and you in a happy
position and and I I wish those students
well I do however think that there are
too many students today who are not in
that fortunate position to be able to
study um purely for for uh other reasons
than than employment uh who are
occasioned to enter into degree programs
for which they are not best suited or
which are not best suited to give them
the skills for their later
life thank you other representative for
um well we heard the clich say about
basket weaving and actually some basket
Weavers make good money but there aren't
many openings at the top of the basket
weaving industry but um yes that's why I
refer to median earnings yes and of
course then you get the uh
um um and then but then they uh well you
we got a letter from the uh director of
government relations for University CST
of New Hampshire and most you I'm
probably the only one who printed it up
and was then able to find my copy of it
but uh
where first of all they um don't have
the earnings data for all of their
graduates they would have to get it from
the IRS although um UNH and most most
universities colleges do make an effort
to keep track of their students so I'll
get to that later that they um do but so
the first and uh so then they're going
to say there is a program called the F
Financial value transparency and gainful
employment Reg fge e and that's been
apparently uh in the works for several
years and uh
unfortunately that program is run by the
IRS and not sure what's happening to all
the IRS agents but I think a lot of them
have been slashed with the chainsaw and
the Department of Education which
theoretically has been dismantled so
you've got at least a non-exist an
agency that supposed at least
ostensively is non-existent U running
this program that we're relying on and
um so that's that's one problem uh this
data this data the only data source we
had to work of is one we can't really
rely on existing in the future but um so
that's a one problem with it we're also
we're trying to punish the educational
institutions for decisions you know
individual decisions made by uh made by
by the students and some of those work
out better than others you know some
people make good money out of basket
weaving some people go on the law
medicine and don't do so well it's has
to do a lot with the individuals more
than the choice of degree
but then on the other hand we're talking
about the
marketplace uh colleges universities the
major ones like UNH or uh the one I um
the ones I went to they make a lot of
effort to try to keep track of the
graduates to like you know encourage
them to network encourage them to earn
more money and uh encourage them to be
as generous as possible in the future
after they get their degree um with
their their earnings they these
institutions do I I believe have a
vested interest in um you know trying to
maximize the earnings potential of their
graduates even after they graduate so
it's not just they take the tuitions and
fees and then ignore them for the next
you know years of the life because most
people graduate when they're about 22 so
they have about you know they've got
like many decades of life ahead of them
so I would probably uh I probably say we
can probably actually rely on the
marketplace uh to uh for them to prepare
people for life and as I said it's hard
to tell uh which degrees work out well
as I said some people some people if
you're very good at basket weaving you
can actually make good money out of
basket weaving it's probably harder than
law or medicine and plenty of people go
in the law medicine or whatever and they
fail at it so all right great
representative
tur yeah thank you Mr chair so you know
I look at this amendment and I I I know
I don't get to probably raise questions
of whether it's totally Germaine or not
but um you know this feels very
different than the bill that I read the
original
Bill uh
didn't allow you to make a free market
decision about the value of Education it
more or less told you what a good value
was or wasn't and sort of made you sign
waivers this seems
to implement a whole completely
different scheme around how um
information would be compiled how it
would be shared what it would contain
sort of using you know retrospective
data to to make Prospect effective
judgments and I guess I would say I I
find it kind of surprising that this is
kind of just an amendment to the
original bill this could have a whole
hearing all by itself in my mind I can
think of a whole bunch of questions that
I would have would have asked here so I
I don't know whether or
not something other than passing this
would be possible but it seems like this
needs a lot more consideration than sort
of an amendment that we all just at
right
representative uh bur
sorry I would just start off as a
preliminary matter in in response to
what representative tur said and it's
not directed against the representative
filed this I have a general polic
problem with filing complete rewrites of
bills uh at the executive uh at the uh
exec session and not having any input by
the public no fiscal note which this
thing clearly would require a major
fiscal note because the impact on the uh
uh schools universities and colleges in
New Hampshire would be massive and then
we have nobody with specific expertise
to ask the particular questions of so
that's a general objection not just
specific to this bill all right uh but I
want to ask a question or two about on
page three the return of inv on
investment section that the institution
shall be required to estimate the median
salary outcomes of some college student
who comes in not knowing what he or she
wants to do perhaps doesn't even know
what their major will be and yet the
school will be responsible for in
writing estimating the median salary
over time and then further the school
would be required to uh indicate by
example the characteristics of students
who should be expected to earn more or
earn less more or less uh and I think of
um when I went to law school and the
particular law school that I went to uh
graduated a number of graduates uh to
very high-end law firms and graduated
probably an equal number to teaching
profession and um I don't know how a
school law school or otherwise I'm just
using that as an example um would be
able to
predict for who would be more successful
at the beginning in earning this amount
of money versus earning that amount of
money and then provide
objective guidance to which kind of
student will do better in teaching and
which will do better in a high-end law
firm and I just think this is a trap for
universities and colleges and an open
invitation for lawsuit after lawsuit
from individuals have nothing better to
do than try their luck at getting 50% of
their uh educational money back at un
at open-ended cost to the taxpayers so
do you have a thought about
that representative McFarland thank you
Mr chairman uh to representative
Horgan's points and I do have the same
copy of the University system of New
Hampshire's comments on the original
Bill uh in front of me I I would say
first of all that the fge uh act then
and the work that the IRS is doing and
that the US Department of Education is
doing um does go some way in this
direction and you bring up a very good
point that if we have an expectation
that some of those
institutions uh may be reduced in size
and scope um then it's all the more
reason why we should be wishing to pass
this bill um and the the other point
that I would make um I I won't go back
into the the conversation about what
types of degree
um but I will say that to the the point
that you raised around the availability
of uh some of this data um that is
called for uh I've actually included a
clause that
provides where data is unavailable um
that that does not uh stop them from
fulfilling the the terms of of the the
required data here as long as they uh
disclose that fact um to representative
Toro's point about whether it's Jermaine
or not I will say that I was at pains to
ensure that it is Jermain precisely by
uh sticking only to the uh the precise
structure and topics of the original
bill um and I defer to the chairman as
to whether we need to get into a debate
on that um and finally uh I would answer
representative Burch by observing that
um while we can have a prolonged debate
over the points you bring up at the end
of the day uh there is no incumbency on
these educational institutions to spend
any money at all on this um they can
simply choose to have the the
matriculating students sign off on the
disclosure statement uh on on the
disclaimer statement um on the other
hand uh some of those institutions May
view this as an excellent competitive
opportunity uh to put their best foot
forward and provide information and you
ask about return on investment and I say
to you that um the the information that
is asked for there is not to look into a
crystal ball it is to look at hard facts
and statistics and provide indication as
to median outcomes and typical details
um so if they feel that they can do that
great and if they don't they can just
have them sign off on a piece of paper
all right um anyone
else wh yes uh thank you Mr chair um so
um I have a couple questions surrounding
this uh return on investment as well um
it just seems unclear to me how um any
kind of educational institution is going
to be able to um give a clear picture of
return on investment when there's so
many outstanding questions that they
don't know for instance um I I went to
school in Pennsylvania but here I am in
New Hampshire so you know where I live
then affects how much money I am uh
going to be paid um I was a teacher um
it it also doesn't take into
consideration whether you're working in
Private Industry or public industry
one's usually paid more than the other
and um as as far as the disclaimer goes
if that's the answer to everything will
then just sign the disclaimer then I'm
curious as to why we need the bill um
not to mention that it's four pages long
and I don't read that quickly legal e so
all right any other anyone else wish
should be heard representative pno I
thank you Mr chairman I would just like
to make a quick point that on on line 27
on page on the first page of the
amendment and on line 16 on the first
page of the underlying Bill any
education institution seems to imply
public or private institutions and I
don't believe we have any jurisdiction
or authority over private institutions
of Higher Learning so to begin with we
would have to amend
that all right um anyone else wish to be
heard so I guess I just the only comment
I would make is I I'm representing mcfar
I'm I'm very sympathetic to what you're
trying to get at I really am but um I I
guess I I you know
I from my general philosophical
perspective I I do I do still think that
the do you know the doctrine of cavat
emper uh means something and I'm really
concerned that this
is to at least to some extent it's
there's there's a certain Nanny State
feel to this that I just don't um I I
can't go along with so um although I'm I
understand what you're trying to get at
I'm sympathetic to some of the things
that what uh sort of outrageous charges
that some schools are making I'm I I
cannot for those reasons I cannot
support the amendment anyone else wish
to be heard on the amendment all right
so um anybody I would propose to have a
raise of hand it's on the amendment um
unless anybody objects to that all right
I've seeing no OB
so I say all those in favor of uh uh
representative McFarland's Amendment
which is number 20250
965h please raise your
hand three all right hang on four wh
four I'm sorry uh ra your raise your
hands again please if you're in favor of
the amendment okay one
two three all right
three all right so three in favor if
you're opposed to the amendment please
raise your hand one two whoops one two
three
four 15 15 all right all right so the
amendment
fails
um 15 uh 3 to 15 all right so now we're
back um to the main bill um and the
chair uh recognizes representative Smith
or your designate for a
motion oh um oh yeah I'm sorry Mr chair
I think representative McFarland has to
withdraw his OTP before he can entertain
so that's a good I mean you thank you Mr
chairman so um I I withdraw my motion to
uh OTP the bill and make a motion to
retain the bill
right is there a second for the motion
to
retain seeing none the motion uh fails
um hang on one
second all
right so now um we're on to
um is there another motion from
representative
tur I'd like to move itl all right ENT
representative tur moves itl is there a
second seconded by representative Manos
all
[Music]
rightl second man all right um
representative tur uh you don't need to
say anything further unless you want to
but if you want to we're we're all ears
I do not all right all right anybody
else wish to be heard on the motion of
itl on House Bill
722 I'd like to make one very brief
comment and that is I would like to know
at some point when we don't have to
violate privacy um where in fact our
colleague representative McFarland was
educated because clearly
um the r
oi is very high thank
you all right uh any further comments
all right then I'd ask the clerk to
please call excuse me to please call the
role on House Bill 722 the motion before
us is inexp inexpedient to legislate
Vice chairman Manion
yes representative Alexander no
representative trip
yes representative Andrew yes
representative kutab
yes representative Perez
no clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes representative C
yes representative Smith
yes representative Horgan yes
representative Burch
yes representative Harvey
yes representative Manos
yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo
yes representative berson
yes and chairman Lynn yes chairman may I
check hang on I I just wait we're just
kind of in the voting mode yeah I'll let
you make your comment but let's finish
voting what's the what's the vote 16 16
y two nay oh did you wish to change your
vote is that what your that's what I was
contemplating based on but I I'm going
to refrain from that thank you all right
so it's the vote stays as 16 to two is
that it yes
162 um oh all right so representative
tur since you made the motion it looks
like it's your report to right will
there be a Minority
Report yeah can we I'm okay with consent
all right anybody have a problem with
consent all right so uh
consent representative Turell will write
the uh the report all right um no
minority no Minority Report no
um all right um so we have that takes
care of 722 we have two bills left
uh um 195 and
522 um they are in some sense related uh
so with regard to uh HP 195 um I'm going
to recognize myself and I will make a
motion of
otpa with hang
on yeah so I I make a motion of uh otpa
and the amendment that I offer which you
all should have is
0890 is there a second representative
Smith apparently representative Smith is
seconding it thank
you all right um so
um if I uh could briefly speak to this
motion um
find it now um so this um this bill as
you may recall this bill is a bill that
was passed by the house last year it
died in the Senate there are a few
changes but um that really resulted from
um the uh
confused uh the discussions that came up
at the hearing
oh I'm on uh rep uh 195 with Amendment
08908 0890
H I only have
0891 oh wait a minute wait a minute now
hold it did I that's correct that's
right
0890 okay I
I okay I'm sorry I can only find 08
91 minute is two okay I'll find it is 08
91 doesn't have I hear it I have it I
have it okay no no that
0890 is is 195 right that's what we're
talking about 195 we're talking about
195 so you know represent I'm sorry can
I just ask you when when you say 0891 is
that also related to 195 because I want
to make sure no that's 522 okay all
right so 089
o is the amendment to um House Bill 195
um and it makes uh it
makes um a few changes in the in
language that were um discussed uh at
the hearing and and some discussions
after the hearing
um uh for example I um it adds on on
page
one of the amendment on line 28
it adds the language unless specifically
authorized by law um I believe that that
were one of the people that um either
testified at the hearing or spoke with
us or me afterwards said that that
language was was important to um for
their interest to make sure that if
there were other was another
authorization uh another law that
authorized something would be all right
um uh the let
me um on page two on line 8 there is a
new subdivision e added as another sort
of exception and that was again
suggested by former representative Kirk
I think a very good suggestion it said
look it basically he basically said look
there may be sometimes when when a
third-party provider of information or
Services needs to make some disclosure
to another entity I guess for example
might be a credit card company or
something in order to provide the
service that the person has asked for
that obviously should be covered um the
uh see let me see if there's any the
um the oh the the language I'm I'm going
to turn then to page three and you'll
see that there is
um I changed the language um in both
Roman numeral
2 uh and I'll specifically refer you to
lines U 8 through 11 the Lang the Lang
you'll see that the language now reads
provided however that no such notice
shall be given if the government entity
seeking the information requests that
such notice not be provided and
demonstrates good cause for making such
request um or a court has issued an
order that such notice not be given uh
and I think that's um it just seems that
that that that language made more sense
um uh that that even if a the way it was
worded before arguably could be read
that unless there was a statute or
something like that that allowed the uh
the another statute that would mean that
allowed um the government
agency
uh to to to require that a respondent
not disclose disclose information then
they couldn't do it it seems to me that
this it makes more sense to say that
they have to demonstrate good cause and
if they can't demonstrate good cause
then they then the the the provider will
uh will notify whoever is the subject of
the subpoena and the same thing applies
in in uh line uh in Roman numeral 3 at
lines
16-9 uh um the uh let see if there's any
other changes
um uh no I think that's I think that's
really it I and I I guess I would say I
don't I mean I think the changes that
were made are I don't want to
characterize them as not being
substantive I think they are to to the
extent I've sort of mentioned it but in
terms of you know do any of them make a
major change to the bill I don't think
they do and I think the bill still makes
um great sense for the same reason it
made sense last year uh oh I'm sorry one
most important thing I was um in
paragraph in uh on page one lines 8 and
10 8 through 10 the definition of
available to the public is
changed to um to read available to the
public which means means personal
information about an individual which is
widely known or readily accessible to
the public and in which an individual
could not have a reasonable expectation
of privacy that I think that if you read
the language of the original bill it
it it was really I think uh much uh
um Much More Much vager and didn't um
uh didn't sort of capture what I think
the case law and I think constitutional
Provisions would say is what an
expectation of privacy is so I think
that uh makes subsection one
uh much just much better so for those
reasons I um I think this bill makes
sense as um as we said last year it adds
to the to 255 by Pro providing a greater
level of protection in particular it has
the opt-in provision that says if you
are one of the covered third party
providers of information and services
and you want to get a consumer like us
to consent it has to be in a a specific
thing that uh a specific request it
can't be you know along with a bunch of
other stuff and you have to be you have
to specifically make a an affirmative uh
Act of consent uh so it can be done
online but it has to be you know
separate are you consenting to this
disclosure and you have to affirmatively
say yes I think it makes a lot of sense
um and I hope you'll support it anyone
else wish to be
heard yes representative McFarland thank
you Mr chairman um so I I very much
appreciate some of the work that's been
done in this amendment I mean including
the the item on page one that you were
alluding to that I think is responsive
to some of a
conversations um I I want to be in a
position to vote for the amended bill
and I unfortunately still have
significant concerns over the amendment
as written and and maybe I am missing
some facts here so I'll just throw out a
couple of of comments on the amendment
the first is with regard to page two um
line two it uses the word
necessary and
I would suggest that it ought to say
something more like appropriate because
there are going to be circumstances
where um the the third party provider is
um desirous of of uh using um other
service providers and and vendors and
and
subcontractors uh but an argument can be
made very cleanly that it is not
necessary and I think that brings me to
the next point which is that in general
um I don't see in here any language that
permits the third party provider of
information and
services uh to routinely use these other
vendors and subcontractors and I know
you made reference to the um paragraph e
the information is disclosed in order to
provide the services and and I think
that one arguably would Encompass some
subcontractors
uh but only to the narrow extent that
that is um aligned with and necessary to
provide the service and is not something
that is ancillary to um the the
provision of the service but but
nevertheless part of the routine
operations of the the third party and so
um if I'm missing something there I
would be grateful to hear about it I
think the next thing I would bring up is
that in line again page two line 24
425 um the ability
to uh provide information to those
government
entities is conditioned on the
government entities requesting them but
it's not clear uh how the third party
could voluntarily seek to provide
information uh which again is something
that I think is a a matter of routine uh
operations especially for the the same
kind of reasons as are laid out on on
lines 1 to three without rising to
actually reporting a crime or having any
any reason such as that to uh to to to
come back to them so um if I'm missing
some language in here Mr chairman I
would be happy to hear about it so I I
guess what I would respond I I I I I
don't think that my inclination from
what you said is I don't think you are
missing anything but I think that that
other words you you know just to give
you you gave the example of um well
subsection e on page two allows the
information to be disclosed in order to
uh to another uh in order to provide the
service that the individual has
requested and you suggested well what if
the business's routine is to disclose
information to another another business
not necessarily to provide the service
but just because it's kind of anelar and
we've always done that and I and I guess
my response to that would be I think I
me you know that that is one of the
things that this is designed to stop it
I think it if you read the
exceptions I think they're designed to
say look a business should be able to do
all of the
things and and use the personal
information of somebody for all of the
reasons that I think all of us would say
is legitimate to provide you know if the
if the credit card company needs to have
my personal information so that when I
buy something from Amazon they can I can
they can allow me to pay for it sure
Amazon should be able to do that um but
if it's if it's not for that purpose if
it really is you know they they don't
have to do that they but they do it
because for some other other reason
that's really not reasonably necessary
to their business then that that is what
this is designed to stop it's designed
to say look businesses if you you've got
this kind of personal information fine
it's why it's fine to use it for things
that are related to uh your business or
for other reasons when um um you're uh
you know there's a legitimate reason but
not for just you can't be sort of sloppy
with uh with it and I think that's you
know that's kind of what this bill was
all designed to prevent yeah and and I
think you know as a privacy Advocate I I
certainly um amendable to that sentiment
in general in fact you know and I didn't
make a comment about it but your comment
on page three about the the language in
8910 I mean I um frankly I I I think
that we should be asking these companies
only to uh not disclose uh when they're
receiving you know a request uh that's
targeted an individuals information when
there is um you know a a court uh uh
order and and a requirement to keep it
confidential I'm I'm troubled by the the
the the option A on on line 9 on page
three but but back to the point on page
two I think what I'm saying is not about
frivolous types of act on the side or
acts that are maybe related to you know
marketing or something else that we're
trying to stop um but but I mean I I I
guess um without thinking through every
possible circumstance if if the word
necessary in in line two was said
appropriate uh I I probably could uh um
you know get past that well let mean
does it help you at all that it says has
reason to believe that it's necessary in
other words it's not I think the test I
I I assume the test under that would be
did the did the third party provider act
reasonably and thinking it was necessary
you know as opposed to sort of
absolutely was necessary I I would think
that you know that that does set a
standard of
reasonableness other other comments yes
uh yes representative bur and again this
is more question of
clarification uh which arises a bit from
what the representative raised the
question of turning over information to
the government which uh
under whatever section that is that he
was by
request so let's move to which I think
is fairly limited I mean if I come AC if
I'm a business and I come across
something that I think the government
should know right I I hopefully won't
have to wait for request from no no
that's what that's what B on the top of
page two is to uh um be be does not on
the top of page two is designed to cover
the situation where there is no request
from the government where the business
is acting on its own initiative because
it has reason to believe that there's uh
you know that there's something wrong
going on uh right criminal fraud
activity identity theft Etc so using
that provision and going over to the
next page when a third party provider
discloses that information presumably
under B I'm wondering how
the two time factors uh interplay one on
line 15 that says the provider shall
promptly uh provide that notice to the
individual so hold on to the word
promptly unless the government
demands that it not be turned over more
or less so what is a provider supposed
to do when he turns it over and the
government person says well that's
that's interesting and important uh
we'll get back to you so does the
provider then ignore the promptly and
wait for the government
to respond in a day a week or a month or
does the provider do promptly and I
don't know how can you suggest how those
two are reconciled I'm I'm I'm I'm not
quite sure I'm following so does the
provide the providers turn over the
stuff which comes first promptly
disclosing it or waiting for the
government to to demand that you
don't I I think promptly I think B on
page two is not is is designed let me
hang on one second let me just make sure
I've read this correctly one two one
yeah I get the B I'm on talking about
page three yeah line 15 versus
15 okay
so
pursuant two1 C
disclosure proly have disclosure which
Master does not has made disclosure to
the individual does the person answer to
first
uh well no I I mean if the if the
provider of information is is providing
the information not in response to a
request
right but in response to um
a you know its own its own suspicion
that something's
wrong um
the the
provider the provider would then I I
think that the provider would promptly
notify the like the credit card holder
or whoever it was it's the person I mean
it's the person who who has the Privacy
interest so disclosing it to that person
I don't but suppose it's it's a computer
a computer image of a child a bad image
of a child on a computer and they notify
the government uh properly that there's
something wrong here um the government
May well
want the uh the company holding the
computer not to turn over that
information hey we to told this to the
government right but they're under an
obligation to promptly tell the uh the
imager what we turned over so which goes
first sure so no but I mean wouldn't I I
think the the reasonable way to read
that would would be would it not if if
the company discovers the child image
and turns it over to the government
right right wouldn't I I mean I would
presume that under that that the person
turning it over would say to the
government we're going to dis we're
going to disclose this to you know
whoever uh we have to disclose it to
under the statute unless there's a re
unless you tell us there's a reason not
to do that and presumably the the the
mean I suppose if they say if the
government get an immediate answer if
the government said no I mean that they
don't get an immediate answer they turn
it
over I mean I guess I I suppose that's
right if they've asked and the
government can't give them an immediate
answer yeah I think they probably do
yeah I I wonder I don't know um if the
law school that you went to and the law
school that um my colleague
representative Burch went to um use the
same uh technique for teaching
law um but whether it is the Socratic
method but my question is is this
conversation which is fascinating for
all of us thank you going to to make any
difference in how anyone votes on this
bill and have we perhaps exhausted the
pleasure of an intellectual
exchange um and we could move on and
it's not that I'm going to say we pass
this bill it passes the house and we
rely on the Senate to fix it because I
don't ever rely on the Senate to fix it
but I also just wonder if we could move
Mo the conversation forward now you you
are very kind and I think I I suspect
that representative bur and myself have
have have kind of gotten into the law
school debate I suppose which everybody
wants to fall asleep for so I would I
have no further comments does anybody
else have any comments on uh
amendment
0890 to House Bill 195 if not um I would
ask uh can we do this by a show of hands
on the amendment or does anybody want a
roll call
all right so the uh seeing no objection
to to a show of hand so all those in
favor of uh adopting amendment
0890 to House Bill 195 please raise your
hand 17 all right so it appear 17
all right amen right have to get the
other V yeah no I know
amen um what is it
h right 170 all right so now we're on to
the main motion um ought to pass um as
amended and I would move uh ought to
pass as amended representative Smith is
there a second second I question all
right all right yes good good all right
so this will be a roll call on the
motion is otpa on House Bill 195 with
Amendment 0890
oh yeah no I'm sorry yes I'm ready
absolutely Vice chairman Manion
yes representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes representative McFarland
no representative C
yes representative
Smith representative Horgan no
no representative Burch since we already
have a bill that covers this
no representative
Harvey
yes representative
Manos
no representative tur
yes representative Rambo
no Representative berson
no and chairman Lynn
yes 11 y six
Nays all right um I will write the
majority report does is there going to
be a Minority Report it has to be
bur to yes
I I think someone else may have their
hand raised well I I I will what do you
recommend any it doesn't have to be a
Minority Report but if anybody yeah I'm
I'm I'm certainly interested in putting
in a minority opinion I don't know if
it'll be the same minority opinion as
representative
Birches all right all right umor just so
it's not a 30 page
document all right so McFarland will do
the uh
minority but I'm glad to consult with
the good rep
representative all right we have one
bill left 522 which is um a
um 522 is the companion to
so 522
um let me find it make sure I've got the
right
one um
so all right so I'm going to
um on
522 I just want to make sure I've got
the right one yes so I'm going to uh
recognize myself and I'm going to move
ought to pass on 522 with amendment
29h is there a
second all right so um moved by Lynn
seconded by Smith uh let me find it here
all right and
um I would like to uh speak to the
amendment the um this this bill as I
said before is the companion of 195 195
is directed at the third-party providers
of information and services as we
um as the same as last year 195 does not
contain a private right of action um
it's limited to the the Attorney General
enforcing it 522 is directed
against the government governmental
entities um that
receive in private information from
third party providers of information and
services and it is it U says what th
what the th what governmental entities
can then do with the
information um that they get from
thirdparty providers of information and
services and this bill is the way it is
drafted the the there are two main
operative SE uh sections section two
which be Roman numeral 2 which begins on
line 28 States the the the general broad
proposition unless specifically
authorized by Statute no government
entity shall acquire collect retain or
use any personal information of an
individual residing in New Hampshire
from any third party provider
um so you might say if you read that
well boy that they third uh government
entities can't do very much at if
anything
with uh private information but three
then sets out what they can do with
private
information which with information
obtained from third party providers and
if you read through Roman numeral 3
sections a through
G it basically says that governmental
entities can do can use private
information rained from third party
providers for or any legitimate purpose
I mean I'm that's that's I'm summing
that up but if you read through it
that's what it says so that it's a
very the exceptions are very very Broad
and I you know as as I think we may have
discussed I don't anti unless government
now is keeping
information uh for some that they that
they don't need to have or or using for
some nefarious purpose which I believe
in New Hampshire is not the case at
least I hope that's not the case in most
cases um the operations of government
should not change at all uh if this bill
passes um but what the bill but this
bill unlike 195 this does contain an
opportunity for a private right of
action against the government um or
government agents um and would allow um
first of all it would may it makes a
knowing violation a misdemeanor
and secondly um it allows for private
right of action to recover either the
greater of actual damages or
$1,000 for each violation so again I
think I think this makes sense
um I don't think it will make a ma any
kind of major change in existing law and
to the extent that you know it it stops
some government entity
from collecting information that it has
no real reason to collect or disclosing
it uh when it has no real reason to
disclose it then I think that's a good
thing um so I would move the amendment
anyone else uh wish to be heard
on seeing n oh I'm sorry yes oh oh okay
all right so is everybody is everybody
all right with a show of hands vote on
the amendment yes so i' say all those in
favor of amendment 09 29h please raise
your hand
17 all right appears that that uh the
motion passes
to0 uh hang
on all right so we're now on to the main
motion of ought to pass as amended and I
move that and I there a second
representative
Smith thank
you all right um any further discussion
on
um on HB
522 uh as amended um the motion being
ought to pass as amended any further
discussion all right seeing none um ask
ask the clerk to call the
role Vice chairman Manion
yes representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab
yes representative Perez yes clerk votes
yes representative McFarland yes
representative C
yes representative Smith
yes representative Horgan yes
representative bur yes representative
Harvey yes representative Manos yes
representative tur
yes representative Rambo
yes representative berson
yes and chairman Lynn yes 17 y zero
Nays all right can this go on consent
um all right and uh I'll write the uh
I'll write the report on
this Mr Mr chair um I would particularly
like to thank the substitutes who sat
through um a very difficult time and I
would also like to ask if we could
request that representative Harvey be
assigned to come and sit behind
representative burch's
chair
second
yes it hasn't worked
yet all right I am I I think we got
through everything we needed to get
through am I correct on that I think I
think so and I
think oh no thank you for thank you for
being here and for your you know for
your contribution for sure um you're
awesome I think we are now done with all
the house bills that so our next our
next uh task will be next week to um
deal with the the uh presentation from
the Human Rights Commission which is
very important and then um then we will
begin getting Senate bills been not too
long and we'll deal with them so again
uh we have maybe we'll have at least a a
little bit of a break uh but thank you
all for hanging in there and I sorry we
didn't get to the 2:00 presentation but
maybe they're still going on let me just
tell you that it will go on probably 6
okay so I would really want to go I'm
I'm going over I want do we have a
leftover question about where the chair
went to law
school I where is that a serious oh I
went to Yukon law
school I'm a Connecticut
native all right well at least you both
went tow school starting with the letter
c
pardon oh oh thank you you know what no
you know what can I ask can I asked to
have the reports by say Friday at noon
time is that
reasonable Friday at noon okay that'd be
great all right terrific all
right all right great thank you
everybody for